years of audio kids in the smodcast
podcast archives that you can stick into
your ear holes and listen to or do you
want to look at something are you one of
them dirty cucks well then go to the
smithsonian screening room where you can
watch hundreds of hours of video of my
entire career spanning from the
beginning up till now including my daily
morning show wake and bake man will we
just smoke weed hang out and i tell you
what i'm working on plus there's
exclusive events we've had clerks three
screenings for our club members we've
had smod castle exclusive shows for our
members back in jersey we do events all
the time including movies pop-ups and
there's tons of merchandise of course
that that kevin smith club members get
exclusive access to before anybody else
there are so many ways into that kevin
smith club ladies and gentlemen you
don't have to come through the front
door you can come through the back door
we like it that way sign up as a clerk
where you get access to all the audio
that we got or join as a mall rep that
gives you all the audio and all the
video as well or join as a fun employee
ladies and gentlemen you'll get a new
t-shirt an exclusive that kevin smith
club t-shirt every quarter or join as a
yoga hoser and get yourself something
cool like that kevin smith wake and bake
bowl ladies and gentlemen those are our
existing levels but what about the new
levels that's right for 2022 we've added
some levels including the fashionable
mail you get everything that the clerk
the mall rat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of wardrobe from
a kevin smith film straight out the
viewers universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rep the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house i
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bacon it goes
up on smodcast man very exclusive once a
year we do that join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be
them all right be a fun employee be a
yogas or be a fashionable male be a
ranger danger or be a golden calf ladies
and gentlemen i'll be waking and baking
for you come join me at that kevin smith
club
[Music]
holy crap ladies and gentlemen
it is time kids it's time
to get behind
me and mark bernardin
as we bring you the finds
of pop culture it is fat man beyond time
ladies and gentlemen i'm kevin smith i
am mark bernardin hi
oh
kids
welcome to uh i guess june i don't think
we've done this in june yet have we or
did we
uh i i don't think so it has been
as they say
a minute
last time we did a show
uh
i think mandalorian season one was
unknown we uh we did talk about kenobi i
remember that
we talked about the first the first two
episodes of kenobi
um we talked about top gun maverick
yeah that's right you saw maverick i
still haven't gotten to see it i went
and had covid i think i talked about
that though too didn't i um
um ever since then they announced
masters of the universe season two
um revolution yes revolution uh i've
been sitting on that information for
like a
long long time
very quiet about it so i was so
delighted when they put it out there
um i just finished a script on this
other
thing i'm working on
and now i'm diving into a new movie
script this morning i got up and i was
like i think i'm going to start writing
a movie
and um what
what rare error
i'm breathing i mean look anybody can
get up every morning and be like i think
i'm going to write a movie but i i do it
with a pretty good like 90 chance that i
can make it come to life as well
and um
i was just i was explaining to my wife
like
when you
when people like uh try to have affairs
and [ __ ] like that
it seems like they're always trying to
start like something new everyone likes
the beginning of a thing right like dart
is something and [ __ ]
and it's you know all the [ __ ] crap
that happens at the end of that that
nobody wants to think about and stuff
i was like i i don't like do that with
people
like i do that with scripts when i start
a new script like
it is like oh my god like what are the
possibilities here
like what's gonna happen like never mind
the ones that you get paid to write you
know what's gonna happen there because
generally there's an outline but the
thing that you write for you man like
where do we go you know you have a vague
idea you have like five points to get to
that'll get you from credits to credits
but you don't know what all these
[ __ ] are gonna say
and like every day is a goddamn
adventure where it's electric where
you're discovering
this the story and like
finding nuances and falling in love with
it hardcore and it's this weird romance
that you know
will come to an end
like it's intense it burns [ __ ] hot
as hell
but then at the end of it all like
you will be done with the screenwriting
and it will become
something else if you're lucky
so like i'm in that period i woke up
this morning like when i'm in writer
mode that i want to write something or
i've got like oh i got a few ideas i
want to get out like you can't [ __ ]
make me sleep like i was at 4am this
morning just like pounding [ __ ] keys
normally i'm up at 4am pounding my dick
right here in the autumn
today prolific with the words and and oh
my god it was just such joy every once
in a while i remember
how wonderful it is to be a writer like
you're never bored you can never be
bored in this life
if you could just sit down with a
keyboard and [ __ ] start
crafting a little world so i've just
been having a
[ __ ] blast doing that that's part of
the blast the other part of the blast is
my mom is out here
oh grace that's right grace is in town
amazing grace herself my sainted [ __ ]
mother ladies
and um
she was here the first night she got
here on sunday
monday morning
i went down to the room to say hey mom
good morning she's on the floor splayed
on the floor my 76 year old mother
and you know you've been in my house it
ain't like plush carpets it's all
[ __ ] hot tile so i'm like no
like on my watch on day one
but she had kind of slipped out of the
bed and stuff and that's when i had to
turn up my
my game it's no longer like time was mom
could visit and you'd be like all right
like you got this whole
section of the house like call me when
you need me or whatever [ __ ] but now
you know a lot more
hands-on uh care i saw a glimpse of the
future all week mark
and my own future my mom and me have a
very similar body type and everything
like that so i'm like
this is this is where i this is where i
went
is how i end up man like so it's
important to
be friends with people
because like one day
we need help bro
we know as an island yeah it really
really is i mean you start
helpless and you kind of
go out help it's not like helpless and
[ __ ] but like
there's no worse feeling in the world
than like
you know walking in and your mom's on
the mountain
she was in like blankets and [ __ ] she i
was like she fall she's like no i
gently slowly slid off the bed and i use
the blankets to break my fall i'm like
not like
oh sushi macgyvered her way out of the
bed this was this was a toddler breaking
out of a crib she's a [ __ ] avenger
bro like you know you can't stop grace
uh [ __ ] would
so
she's uh been here and and we've been
rolling around having a blast and
whatnot um she loves
her son's world like
everything is fascinating to her and
stuff but yesterday we had this kind of
cool moment we're just bombing around
we went over to the valley
uh we were i was tagging stuff out and
pico
uh is where we have like the warehouse
where we for jay and silentbob.com where
we send all the signed merchandise out
of
them
so my mother loves that [ __ ] i was like
we're going to pico i'm going to sign
like 500 things she's like oh that's
great let's go
so you know she got to see the office
and all that stuff and i signed a bunch
of stuff and then we went back to town
and like i was taking her i didn't tell
her where we're going but i was taking
on this ride
and
like harley called and we were i was
speaking around speaker phone in the car
and she goes where are you and i was
like i'm out with grandma i'm taking
grandma to
and my mother's like what
i was like we're gonna go to tiffany ma
like
you know you're always talking about
like diamond stud earrings
let's go let's go shopping
and
you know
nice feeling to be able to walk in with
my mother and to tiffany and i've you
know spent
20 years of a marriage going to tiffany
so i don't just walk into tiffany and
people are like hello
i walk in like oh sir
oh you are back you're like oh come this
way so they turned it on from my mom
brought her to like the back room and
[ __ ] and brought out a selection of like
studs for her to try on it was adorable
and when the guy went to get the
earrings i told the guy i was like i
told my mom i was like i could predict
that
you know the first time you're gonna put
some studs in
and then he's gonna tell you how much it
costs
you're gonna you're gonna stop all of
this instantly
and she was like oh we'll see and she
had picked out this very you know modest
pair of studs but it's tiffany and so
the dude flipped the tag and my mother
like flipped her [ __ ] wig she was
like
are you what are you mad what are you
kidding and i was like you don't have to
get those in fact i'd prefer it if you
did
smaller cheaper
earrings and stuff but uh she picked
them out and stuff she'd been wearing
them around like a
proud peacock and [ __ ] like and so i
just want to take this opportunity
to thank all the people that have
supported my
[ __ ] since 1994. this is what i do
for a living i like you know [ __ ]
silent bob jane style bob stuff [ __ ]
stuff like this with mark [ __ ]
you know masters of the universe like i
have an unrealistic [ __ ] childlike
life i'm an overgrown
goddamn adolescent for a living and
stuff like that and
because like i've gotten to do stuff for
years and people have been like here's
money make me laugh you [ __ ] idiot
that money afforded me a moment where
like i could be like ma let's go get
those earrings you always wanted it it
was [ __ ] pretty blissful man so thank
you
to anyone who's ever bought a kevin
smith thing and to anyone who's never
bought a kevin smith thing oh are you
missing out go to jay and silentbob.com
done
uh i i had a similar moment
um
a couple weeks ago
because my son
who turned 18 yesterday
on instagram he just turned 18. yeah
he's a man he's a goddamn man now he's
no longer a minor he's reached the age
of majority
um but the week before was his
graduation
and so from high school and so we had
all four grandparents in for the first
time at once including my dad who's
never been out to visit for various like
health related reasons or whatever and
so it was
you know i remember a couple months ago
i was like dad luke is graduating from
high school
on june whatever the hell it was
you know june it was june 4th or 5th
i was like and you have to be there it's
like okay i'll try my best i'm like dad
i will put you on a plane i will fly you
out here i will put you up all you have
to do is say yes i'm coming to his
graduation he's like you know what i'll
be there
and the ability to just
drop that money and put your dad on a
plane and to spend
the money and put all four grandparents
up in a hotel for five days while like
all of that is is again the side effects
the the bounty of the life that we get
to lead which is one of make-believe and
fantasy um where i don't have to build a
thing i don't have to buy anything sold
or sold anything bought or put or or
manufacture anything that's ever sold
purchased or whatever the hell yeah um
buy anything
this whole process or process anything
sold but i don't know sir i'm not gonna
try to figure it out tonight that's why
i hang out with your daughter
what a lovely beautiful movie i remember
seeing that in the theater and for the
first time since john hughes it was like
holy [ __ ] somebody understands us
somebody like really [ __ ] gets the
audience and that was the
camera crow's first flick right yeah say
anything
um but yeah it was just it was nice to
be able to not quite john hammond we
spared no expense but still
i can i can swallow this expense and
it's not gonna it's not gonna cause any
undue
um heartache believe me my my my [ __ ]
clenched my mother picked the foot studs
i was like
oh here
that's how you get robbed in an alleyway
ma that's how pearls go flying and
little boys cry over graves and horns
come out of [ __ ] cows we don't want
that kind of what they don't tell you is
rodeo drive is also an alley and we
don't want to be these things
[Laughter]
uh yeah it was it's been lovely palling
around with mom i left uh like mostly
the whole week open thank god i finished
that
script last week so
you know
um we were able to do stuff just
and emergency stuff like after she
fell down she was like can we go to the
foot talk to her i was like [ __ ] yeah
i'll take you any ducks you want mom i'm
gonna take the bubble wrap doctor he's
gonna wrap you up good and tight
um but she went to the foot doctor and
you know my mom's got like she's 76 she
got these real bad feet and her doctor
in florida is like she's going to be in
a wheelchair any second like you know
this these feet are the worst feet i've
ever seen in my life
and we were at this foot doctor out here
in los angeles and he was recommended by
my uh cardiologist god we sound like
such old men regardless
um i i i was like hey man i needed a
foot doctor for my mom he's like i'll
take this my guy across the street is
wonderful he's my buddy
we go in there and i say the doctor i
was like are these like the worst
[ __ ] feet you've ever seen in your
life
the doctor goes it's not even by a long
shot i had to put together someone's
foot that got blown apart by a shotgun i
was like what he's like oh we get
gangrene we get half feet in here he's
going like how old how old is your mom
75 and she was like i'm 76. she's like
she has 76 year old feet he's going look
you know she's got some of the some of
this and then maybe there's the
beginning of gout or whatever it fell
but like you know he's like that
requires cherry juice like who knew you
know what the gout is
like they called it the king's disease
stuff like few really rich foods that
like meat you know wine
fish fish shellfish and [ __ ]
for some reason they got these
purines or whatever they go right to
your [ __ ] foot so
like you know the guy
i was going well i'm vegan i don't have
to worry about that he goes you kidding
me [ __ ] beans
and i was like beans like like like
pintos and chickpeas he's like oh yeah
he's going cashews i was like i eat all
three of those it's like you got you're
next
so you got to cut it with like cherry
juice and [ __ ] like this
medical science so [ __ ] weird but
this guy says my mom's foot he's like
she's gonna be fine she's gonna be
walking on that for for a while like you
know there's no there's
no harm you know he's like they're not
great but they're not like what you seem
to think they are and stuff right that
was a [ __ ] load off man where i was
like
and then suddenly i was like let's take
you to every doctor in los angeles
what are you gonna have done yeah for
every part of your body and let's see if
they beat the florida doctors and [ __ ] i
love that you have like the pretty woman
montage sequence but with your mom and
doctors
she waltzes in with a [ __ ] urine cup
full to the [ __ ] top she's put his
nap on hands
um yeah it's been lovely and a reminder
kids like you know you get one mother
maybe two if you're lucky in this life i
only got one
so
treat them well go hug them if you can
if you got one nearby and stuff yeah
uncle hug someone else's mother ask
first though
true yeah i guess weird always a good
idea uh i was on the other side of the
arrangement you made which is i had my
you know all four grandparents in for a
week and then my mom stuck around for
another week and that week my mom was in
town
that friday i had a script dude only the
show that i was working on so i you know
you usually get on a tv show
two two and a half weeks to write a
draft of an episode
the first week of that was graduation
week so that was just shock like there
was no dipping off and doing any kind of
work you know i was i was on
i was on the ball that whole time and
then that second week i had to do two
weeks worth of work in one week's worth
of time
and then and then we were supposed to
have a fat man like that wednesday or
thursday whatever it was like kev
it would be if if it's cool with you can
we push this the next week because i
every last minute
i need to spend writing this thing
and uh you were you were gracious enough
to be like no problem it's fine and like
i got it done i turned it in
do you write well under pressure
it is almost the only way that i can
write
right yeah because you know 20 years as
a journalist has instilled the need for
a deadline
like if you give me a deadline you'll
have it when it's when the deadline
expires if i have no deadline i will
take
years to do a thing until somebody gives
me an arbitrary deadline and it can be
[ __ ] it just needs to be a thing
um
yeah the pressure the pressure of either
bills
or deadlines is what gets a thing done
in my house
bills are its own kind of deadline
yeah i'm always like i try to
i don't really treat deadlines all that
seriously and i'm not like a deadline
writer but
i
i do
the the last thing i was working on
like i actually put aside and wrote
something entire i barton thanked it
like remember the colin brothers were
trying to write [ __ ] miller's
crossing and they were like
[ __ ]
can't nail it let's just write this and
they wrote barton fink
and they went back and finished miller's
crossing like as you do
um sometimes you just gotta get out of a
thing go do something else
and then for me at least and fall in
love with just the joy of writing before
it becomes like oh it's a thing i have
to do like it's a thing i always
want to do it's like the only thing i'm
like decent at in life i'm not gonna say
good because the internet will be like
no you're not but like
i could string some words together so
it's nice it's nice to be still be able
to do that still be able to appreciate
it waiting for that moment when
like i don't like this [ __ ] anymore you
know some people get old in this
business and they're like [ __ ] they
get resentful and like
you know i've i'm over it i've had it i
still [ __ ] like megan pretend i'm
still like
i drive out of here you know i've been
driving around with my mom a lot i
passed like the hollywood sign in the
distance it's not like right next to me
but i see at the hollywood sign every
day
and it never gets like
tired for me where i'm like
[ __ ] hollywood that's where they make
movies you know
i hope that never goes away it's real
[ __ ] nice i felt that
watching uh a program or two
that we'll be talking about very very
soon once we
give way to our sponsors but but before
we do that
what was it like
watching your kid graduate
it was
it was it was not as emotional as i
expected it to be because i it to be a
wreck
i expect it to just be this just
blubbling mask
instead you criticized it like
everything else we watch here you're
like i didn't believe it i didn't
believe any of them i
i don't think they earned it you know
better third act
that's the choice you made okay
it's a three and a half hour event for
30 seconds of joy but okay
it was one of those how many kids in the
class um
about 1100 kids
i graduated with
78.
our graduation ceremony was that we
didn't have we had like 900 kids in the
whole school if we were lucky man i went
to that school you saw a little house in
the prairie where they're all in like
one room with miss beetle and [ __ ] yeah
it's like we could do one round of
pumping circumstances and everybody's in
their seats like
um what what'd you get out of it
um
it's no tears
i mean there it was it was emotional it
was emotional once i found him after the
graduation
you know the watching that happened was
just like all right you know i feel
pretty good about it um you know i'm
proud of him needless to say but it was
once he
you know did his thing and you know got
out of his seat and they throw their
caps in the air and then you're just
sitting there like a schmuck as every
other parent is like where's my kid i
don't know there's 1100 kids here i'm
hoping he's there and then when he finds
you and then you get to hug him i think
that's the moment when it was like
you know tender
um
but it was just i i felt
jealous is the wrong word but i know
what that
how the world opens up to you how it out
expands for you once you begin those
giant milestones once it becomes right
you're out of high school now
now you're going to college now you're
gonna you're gonna be who you are
you know you're gonna discover who that
is
and the ability to do that to have that
latitude to to to be a kid who's
becoming
a man who will take care of himself
you know that that was that was more
emotional to me and also this is the
summer of emotion because he's going to
college in like a month and a half
san diego state
so not too far away that's not too far
away
but so it's the like all right he's
going to be moving out of the house
we're going to have to drop him off at
college and then drive away like you've
seen all the movies and trying not to
swerve and crash into trees because your
eyes are full of tears like that
it's it's the beginning of the crest
into
oh [ __ ] he's gone right
and that i don't think ever really
changes because now is the beginning of
he's not living at home anymore not full
time anyway
now is the beginning of like wait a
second
if he's 18
i mean 80 years older
than when we had him oh my god i'm an
old man this is where it starts
sinking in all that make pretend we do
for a living allows us to
stave off age but when the kids
accomplish things and become adults and
grow up and [ __ ]
there's no denying that much time has
gone by yeah no matter how many times i
can wear sweatpants to work in silly
t-shirts so get paid for it um time has
marched
in defiance of my will that's true and
then ironically one day the kids turn
around there's like stop wearing
sweatpants and silly t-shirts around the
house and you're like i worked so hard
72 years old what do you want from me
uh well congratulations uh it's you know
it's it's the parents graduation
as well as the kids and you know you put
in the time for heaven's sakes all the
educating and whatnot indeed
keeping uh keeping the girls up and
pulling the boys off the pipe it's chris
wrote look at that
is here say something he knows a thing
or two about being a dad what's up banff
man i had uh i feel like i haven't been
on the show forever because i missed the
last one that's right
you can hear last time it was will and
will was like all about even that [ __ ]
he was so ready to like throw you under
the bus and take your place he was like
so this is what stardom feels like
he was what was he the dilf
i have i actually have two stories i
usually don't like jump in up front but
i was at i missed the show because i was
at disneyland with my daughter for the
first time they did a special star wars
night and we got tickets
and uh she loved disney she loved the
fireworks we kept her out till midnight
which like what a little champion of a
18 month old kid
uh and then when she went home i
this is going to sound kind of douchey
but i met up with some of my friends one
of them being uh jet lucas who's george
lucas's son
and we were waiting to go into oga's
cantina
and somebody
i know i know i know uh somebody
went up to him and goes hey man i'm
sorry i i recognize you but um
do you mind if you take a picture with
me
and he's like yeah sure
then the guy's two friends walked over
to me and go hey bamf man i recognize
you i want my picture with you
and so
i was like oh my god
zetjukasa who saved bail organa's life
is less famous than i am he only took
one photo
uh and then
i do i do all this stuff for the
hollywood reporter
and i was doing a thing with josh brolin
for outer range
and he showed up early so we were all
just sitting on the zoom
and the hollywood reporter
moderator shows up on the zoom call and
he first thing he says is oh my gosh
he's the world famous banff man on this
call
in front of thanos and i was like oh my
god
he he recognized me before he recognized
josh brolin
i feel like the most famous person in
the world so see man you [ __ ] hang
with us we'll take you places baby
you got access man just take that shirt
down a little bit
yeah we'll make you famous oh my god
that's awesome man like i said that was
weird
when i run into people in the real world
who talk about
this show it always delights me like you
know it delights me when they [ __ ]
say anything positive but like the
movies
i'm i'm accustomed to it's not like
everyone loves the movies like believe
me there are a lot of [ __ ] do
not like these movies that i make at all
but
generally speaking it's more people say
things about the movies when they're
just like oh my god [ __ ] please tell
mark
like
that show is amazing because of him and
i'm like you want me
to pass that on to him because that
sounded like a backhanded [ __ ]
compliment right there
um and i have [ __ ] heard about banff
man too i have a perfect appeal because
i'll be like well jc my friend jc he
owns like this coming villainy cantina
and people will be like oh bamf man i'm
like
i i got stopped at we were only at star
wars celebration for we were there
thursday and friday and then saturday
jen woke up with covid and
you all get the celebration kova that
everybody seemed to get yeah and it was
spaced out wonderfully so jen got it
saturday morning
so she had it for five days and so i
took care of the baby all day and then
worked all night and i was like i didn't
get it and then the day six she tested
negative
and i woke up with feeling terrible with
covet
and i was like oh god then i got through
it day six i tested negative and i'm
like we're all clear the baby didn't get
it we did it and she got sick and she
was sick for two weeks with covet
she just got better
so yeah we we had 20 days of covet
essentially in the house
how does a baby deal with covet
um
she was up coughing all night like
really snotty like her general
temperament is is really good
and she was really whiny and just wanted
to lie down in bed and watch sesame
street with mom
that's all she did for like a week i
mean like
that play that sounds pretty [ __ ]
amazing
i should my mom's here i'm gonna go
[ __ ] lay down in bed with her
real big to be like let's count right
one of these things is not like the
other
the um
how adorable man like but also how
harrowing like could you imagine like we
get sick we got general ideas [ __ ] cause
we've been around for a while
you're [ __ ] one year old and all of a
sudden you're like what is this life
sucks why'd they bring me here
everything is horrible because you've
never really dealt with sickness before
it's a [ __ ] yeah well and she hasn't
been sick because she was a pandemic kid
so she was out of the house very
sheltered yeah so but i did i we were at
celebration for two days
really
and i must have gotten
recognized every 15 or 20 minutes
oh banff man oh scum and villainy oh
bamf man it was wild
that's our those are our people right
there
so yeah it was fun though it was like
what i'm hearing the note behind the
note is we should be doing a disney vlog
disney bounded with kev mark and [ __ ]
bam
yeah well we can see if we can get in on
the what is it the disney's golden
showers or whatever the [ __ ] where for
like 120 thousand dollars
you get to go to all of the disney parks
on a private jet
um i thought you could say like for 120
000.
little mermaid takes a whiz on you i'm
like that's the golden shower deal that
i think a lot of people would i mean
beat a path to disney for they can't
advertise that but
or prince eric
either one
or the dog even if you're into that what
a quite a singing lobster
was he a lobster no was he a shrimp he
was a crab crab that's right
i'm just blind i'm doing this hitting
everything he's was he a mollusk was he
a flu
station
um
yeah man i i uh
i i don't know if i could uh go for that
golden shower deal
i mean i'm thinking you know don't don't
knock it
yeah really well you get to go to all
the parks
let me let me see if i can find this
thing but it was some you know
massive amount of money to go do this
[ __ ]
i mean yeah i'm gonna track it down
don't mind me
let's move along
dead air you know i should be filling
this air but like
i mean you're seeing a lot of lag
apparent people are bitching about a lag
jc
you seeing this lag yeah i'm looking at
i'm trying to figure out
why it's doing that
buffering every five seconds for me you
folks are saying
it's choppy like leonardo's katana for
me too well
me now look at that [ __ ] yeah that's
a writer
that is uh
muted moe
lag super bad buffer man i feel like i'm
getting yelled at i'm uh it looks good
oh no it's getting better close all hub
tabs same buffering i felt the lag was
just me uh oh dude here comes the
insurrection we need the dilf
i think will might have [ __ ] set a
time bomb in your system bro
hit you up with a dirty lag so he could
come in and rescue us [ __ ] tom cruise
and endless love style let me see which
one you see it's just a story that he
told
i know everyone's talking about tom
cruise because top gun maverick i say
reach back to endless love he wasn't
even the star and still he captured your
imagination
a performance that only got better when
he was in taps
and he was just blowing people away his
beautiful man
when he was jacked remember when tom
cruise was like built like a brick [ __ ]
house and taps
is what are we talking about
i turn away from the screen for one
second
remember one time cruz was jacked i went
down to tom cruise rabbit hole between
endless love and
and taft
i know it
it's popular lag is healthy for the body
lagged on him saying lag i
what is well at least i'm high for this
there
no refreshing didn't work
um youtube hates us it's intermittent i
can
i can uh i mean i can stop the stream
but if it reconnects it'll
create a new youtube video
seems fine now
yeah
uh
stream on low latency on obs
says leighton z
and that seems to be his solution to
everything including a screen name
the show has devolved into us going like
is the show on
it doesn't work
is there anybody out there anybody at
all scott murphy says all good now he
says all right now so tucker sebastian
says working for me now dm dad says it's
clearing
i need a hobby says it's better now
it's been pretty stable for a long this
this time all right we're we're doing
good all right
i just clicked back in i don't know
because now people are talking about
taps you know what i'm talking about
yeah went weird obs went rogue on me it
started encoding at crazy frame rate but
it looks good now so all right but carry
on everybody
um do we want to jump into our head
before we go any deeper into bedlam
i was going to try to say that we did
the ad but you didn't see it because it
kept buffering
nice
it's only nice if it would have worked i
know i appreciate a good try to skate
out of doing some work
[ __ ] dude i don't know if you ever
saw my first movie
literally what it's all about
late motif of my life for heaven's sake
who
is our lucky first sponsor
oh i can smell it
smells good could only mean one thing
native's back kids
oh the good folks in native deodorant
tell you something about good folks at
native deodorant man they take the stink
and they put it in the earth where it
belongs they kill your stink and they
cover you with the [ __ ] sweet man
you've heard us talk about how much we
love [ __ ] native man the thoughtful
formulation beyond all their products is
something that i'm reading from a script
obviously but it's something that i've
always loved because they understand
it's not just what's on the inside of
the couch but also on the outside that's
why native is releasing their deodorant
that i know
and love in new and improved wait for it
plastic free packaging why do you have
to kill a dolphin to smell good
ask yourself that
why do you gotta choke a [ __ ] minnow
just cause you don't want to smell like
armpit sweat you don't have to man cause
native's getting rid of all that plastic
which just winds up in the ocean and
[ __ ] like that they're doing their part
to help the earth do your part by buying
native products for heaven's sakes man
how do you do that you go to
nativedeo.com
fat man where you use the promo code fat
man at checkout and you get 20 off your
first order that's native d
the letter e the letter o dot com or use
promo code fat man check out for 20 off
your first order can i tell you
something mark do it in january native
is doing a collab that's how they call
it now the kids call it collab and they
put an x
and [ __ ]
it's native collabing
with baked by melissa
so ev listen to how sweet man uh the
this these fragrances are
on their products
this month in january you get tie-dye
vanilla cupcake
you could smell like thai diving no
cupcake mint cookie cupcake
you could get fresh peach cupcake that
ain't for me i don't go for peaches oh i
love you some peaches i'm gonna bury my
nose in it
do you really yeah
show us how
it's pretty hot
i think i just watched our [ __ ]
numbers take a jump
people like you have my attention mr
peach eater he's going to the beach pit
um ginger lemonade cupcake oh my god man
you could also get classic deodorant
sensitive deodorant body wash plastic
free deodorant shampoo conditioner all
those flavors i'm looking in the wrong
place all those flavors
going right into those products man i
love native i literally love their
products and i use them in my own shower
what the [ __ ] is your [ __ ] excuse
don't have one
that wasn't meant for you i mean i was
talking to that guy and her and that
little one over there
stop stinking kids native
tell them mark
native is also a proud partner of one
percent for the planet and are
committing one percent of their
plastic-free deodorant sales to
environmental non-profits and just like
all of native's other deodorants they're
plastic-free deodorant it's aluminum and
paraben-free kills order-causing
bacteria and has 24-hour protection to
keep you feeling and smelling fresh
so if you're ready to try plastic free
deodorant go to nativedeo.com
fat man or use a promo code fat minute
checkout and get 20 off your first order
um we thank the good folks at native
for uh sponsoring this here episode
first half at least of uh
fat man beyond long-standing native
sponsor
uh indiana
they they like us for whatever reason
i'll tell you it's easy to like them
they smell good [ __ ] tastes good don't
eat it but it smells good enough to eat
um don't do it though
don't but it smells that good put it on
someone and then eat them show em mark
do the peach thing all right
that was it
i mean
i thought you were doing this
my dad was covering you i assumed that
you were showing people how do you eat a
peach
i just buried the nose and shiv it a bit
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
[Laughter]
nicholas hamill says i'm a happy native
user love that citrus orange and body
musk wash there you go
musket body watch really
musk um check this out man you learned
it doing this show
mike ono in chat says a young moth
gideon is in taps with tom cruise
john carlo esposito is is in taps as
well
well let's i mean john kohler especially
was a working actor back in the day
he's in trading
places he's the in the scene where eddie
murphy's uh billy ray valentine is in
jail after he gets arrested by the
police for faking not having any legs
jim carlos dude of standing right next
to him as he talks about the kind of
blood technique
and like yeah i'm a kung fu man i bleed
on the inside
like pimple face dear color esposito
and here i thought like for me i've i
think the first place i saw him was to
do the right thing he was bugging out
he's a long-standing spike guy i saw him
at one of the last cons i was at maybe
the orlando megacon
um
and uh he was rolling by and he said hi
such a sweet dude but impeccably dressed
the best dressed man at comic con man or
woman like
a fashion plate
hands down
um
man oh man wow i get now i gotta i
gotta re-watch taps man again everyone's
like
you know [ __ ]
top gun you really want to impress me
tom cruise sequalize taps
i know your character dies in it but
[ __ ] figure it out
i don't know why you're being so
resistant to maverick
because here's the people don't do it
why because everyone's telling me to
watch it
i told you to watch it a month ago you
know me when everyone told me to wear a
mask i wouldn't do it mark when everyone
told me to get my vaccinations i
wouldn't do it i won't be told what to
do no i will eventually see maverick i
did get to covet and you know was not
thinking about it too much right um i
will watch it i'll i'll promise i
probably won't go see it in the theater
um he don't need my help i heard the
movie did very well yeah 400 million
domestic oh my god my god
it's a man in a plane grow up no i
understand
i get it i'm like my my superhero movies
my superheroes wear masks not helmets
god well i guess some of them wear
helmets
top gun maverick is
what if steve rogers was a pilot and not
a guy who threw a shield
that's what that movie is it is a
completely unironic they have just sold
the ticket my friend
i'm not gonna see kevin why don't they
just put that on the [ __ ] poster
captain america but the plane is a
shield dummy i'm like
he could throw it like nobody else's
business
um
all right man all right we've seen some
[ __ ] yeah
yeah let's talk about some things uh
kids i'm gonna be honest with you and i
know saying this is gonna get me beat up
by some people in chat or on the
internet at large
uh but i have not watched today's
episodes of ms marvel and obi-wan kenobi
i'm not saying we can't talk about them
if mark asks he could totally spoil him
and [ __ ] i'm such a stoner by the time i
sit down to watch it i'll forget that
mark told me about it i ever tell you
that story about the sixth sense my man
[ __ ] rap face was working on it
raphae's our production designer on many
of our movies including the most recent
one clerk's three
and um years ago you know he works like
on our movies he's a production designer
but on m night shyamalan movies he's
like the
buyer or something like that production
buyer or something
so he works on like the me or worked on
the m night shyamalan movies and you
know um one day he told me uh i said
what you've been working on he goes ew i
just got him because he's from
philadelphia i just got him from from uh
in this movie with m knight and he goes
and at the end like bruce willis is it
and i was like was he what does he do he
goes at the end
spoilers he goes he dies
and i was like the [ __ ] out of here he's
like yeah the whole time it turns out
the guy's dead and i was like wow that
sounds [ __ ] cool
that movie comes out i go see it with my
wife in like [ __ ] movie theater in
eatontown and [ __ ]
and i wasn't even stoner then i
completely [ __ ] forgot ratface told
my story so when the third act happened
spoilers i was like
what the [ __ ] what a mind [ __ ]
blowing this is crazy
how crazy is this this
and then i was like wait a second rap
face told me this whole [ __ ] story
like a year and a half ago holy [ __ ]
this ain't no crazy thing i knew about
this [ __ ] thing
i just don't pay attention so the point
is you could spoil obi-wan and i'll
still be able to enjoy it later that
being said i have continued to enjoy
uh obi-wan particularly
the
call it obi-wan kenobi colon the darth
vader show cause good lord they're just
giving us all
the [ __ ] vader man like petty shitty
vader that's what i really love i love
when he [ __ ] met ben kenobi again
they fought
and he lit the [ __ ] ground on fire
and then he forced him onto the ground
and he forced him across the fire and
[ __ ] just to be like you did it to me
you piece of [ __ ] i hope your limbs burn
off i hate you
like just like when he was dying in
revenge of the sith
i thought that was so [ __ ] dope i'm
like not only is this the most fearsome
[ __ ] villain in the galaxy what a
petty [ __ ]
like the point where he like forces me
he sparks a fire with his lightsaber and
he forces obi-wan kenobi through it and
then he forces the fire out again
because he could do that because he has
a force
and then what's her face in they reverma
like she shoots the the the ground again
and then the fire sparks up one more
time and then vader's like i can't do
nothing about this fire he's like i'm
look
i'm new at this
uh this ain't [ __ ] vader from star
wars but like year one vader so i don't
know
how to deal with an exploding
transformer i just do fires and force
chokes
uh and i can only be fired once a night
like i can't do this twice
not that kind of fire
does anybody want to [ __ ] say
something about my fire limitations
the little random
uh i'm sorry
lord vader i don't understand why the
force works sometimes and then not other
times why won't it work i'm trying to
choke you is there a button on your
chest you need to press to reset the
force
how does your throat feel
if you stop the fish you're going to die
i have enjoyed it i know there are some
people that uh you know
i don't my bar is low i guess like you
know i
really can't say this [ __ ] around my
wife because she'll be like the [ __ ]
does that mean and [ __ ] but my standards
are pretty low cause i'm entertained as
[ __ ] man
i'm like are you [ __ ] me this is the
show we dreamed about we were children
like a weekly darth vader show
like
it's crazy it's crazy that's the world
we live in now star wars works
incredibly well as episodic [ __ ]
television um the leia storyline
continues to charm
um you know i continue to have no
problem with [ __ ]
riva i you know i don't i i think she's
i think she's mean i don't know why
people have a problem with it i'm like
it's [ __ ] mean you know what uh
someone had a theory hey bamf man pop in
here
bamf
um i don't know if this happens in the
latest episode but like in the last
episode i watch
reeva is talking to leia and she talks
about like you know [ __ ] nobody's
coming for you like when you're a kid it
sucks or whatever the [ __ ]
do we know anything about these
inquisitors like their backstory because
what i'm starting to [ __ ] smell
and i'll be honest with you it wasn't
just me smelling it by myself mike
zapsic i was in uh jersey at jane sambox
secret stash my comic book store
25 years in business uh this uh weekend
and mike zapsec floated this and i was
like holy [ __ ] do you think all those
inquisitors are meant to be
jedi
younglings
that he didn't kill
so
they reveal in the new episode that she
was
a just her or all of them
uh just
her
as far as
that would be a what a brilliant retcon
that that is honestly like one of the
weirdest
most disturbing moments in all of the
star wars movies and i'm including the
fact when brother and sister
make out
um like when he [ __ ] snaps on the
lightsaber and the kid is like
and [ __ ] like they
they've let us told us for years
that they just butchered all those
[ __ ] kids i thought it would have
been kind of cool and i'm sure people
would have a problem with it you know
because nobody likes anything when
people are happy
but i thought it would have been a
pretty dope retcon if like he didn't
kill those kids like he was like
[ __ ] killing kids and he was like
let's just turn him over to the dark
side and [ __ ] like that and so
ultimately
he wasn't this child killing [ __ ]
you know which makes it like when
in return of the jedi when he's you know
like save me my son he takes his [ __ ]
you know gold my son leave me and he
takes his helmet off and [ __ ] like that
like you know that we saw darth vader
blow up a planet which but really that
was grand moff tarkin
thumb go hell bent for skywalker cut his
[ __ ] hand off tell him he's his dad
and then [ __ ] like not try to save
him when he [ __ ] pitched himself off
and then in the third movie he's like
i'm saving my son it wasn't it wasn't
all bad and [ __ ] like that and there's
redemption
nobody said anything in return of the
jedi like p.s
he killed children
like i know a bunch of children probably
died on alderaan but again that's grand
moff tarkin's thing and [ __ ] the guy in
the mask before he wore a mask like
walked into a church and [ __ ] slayed
children with a lightsaber that's a it's
easily something they could have
retconned and stuff i appreciate that
they didn't
tell me
because we live in a world in an era
where it seems as if the reclamation of
villains
and they turning them into either
anti-heroes or not as bad as you
remember
seems to be a little bit um
pervasive
you know like venom you should be a bad
guy not a bad guy anymore joker kind of
used to be a really bad guy not that bad
of a guy he's getting a sequel it's a
musical would be fun
like the idea that that evil doesn't
just get to be evil anymore you know and
vader as for us our childhood avatars of
what evil meant
and the [ __ ] crimson metal balls of
george lucas as his own studio
to say oh no here's how bad he was
he was
space hitler who was killing children
because they had a strain in their blood
a midichlorian count that made them
enemies of the new world order like
that's [ __ ] dark and the fact that
lucasfilm and disney has not undone that
i i kind of appreciate that because you
want him to be so bad that the
redemption arc is is that long
and that only his son could have done it
like i think that's actually kind of
beautiful and in order for that to work
he's got to be as bad as bad can be and
to george lucas that was he's killing a
bunch of [ __ ] kids and there's a
warning
in front of episode five
that i haven't seen anywhere else on the
show which is
this episode has imagery that might be
troubling
um
given the wake of children being
murdered in their classrooms
the idea that
here's a story about a guy who's
murdering children in their classroom
you got to warn people it's coming and
you gotta
i didn't even put that together my god
that's like
yeah like yeah duh yeah
so a little a little like
in case you are feeling a certain type
of way
and if you're human you are
you might need to be aware of this kind
of they're calling us out again jc yeah
when i've been when i'm bamfing in it
seems like it's causing a problem with
my graphics card so i'm gonna keep my
face off
uh but i'm i have it up on twitch and we
look okay on twitch
so i hope that will catch up on youtube
yeah we're looking okay on youtube now
mega sith says this shouldn't be this
hard to stream hey man like you got to
remember me and mark were born in like
the [ __ ] 70s
well having our own [ __ ] little tv
show that we can literally sit at our
desks our home and
broadcast live to the world like
this is pretty miraculous man i mean
future [ __ ] it's also like if you want
to get technical i updated vmix which is
the program we use to produce the show
to version 25
before we started this like last week
before we did this show
so every time you update software i mean
we we learned that with clerks3 and avid
right every time you update something
it may not play nice with something else
and that's i think what we're
experiencing today a software update
that
uh is now not playing very nice with the
other tools required
um for all the things we talked about
that they missed with the lag would that
be on the show proper or no yeah i i
started rolling a backup copy so when we
if if it's bad on youtube's archive i
will can upload the archive copy and
it'll be super cool i will uh for those
asking the like what did kevin say um i
i should probably not say it because
people would be like you dumb son of a
[ __ ] but i was saying like it seemed i
didn't know the plot of the most recent
episode of obi-wan
where spoilers they reveal riva's
past history connection
as a young link to anakin and uh mike
zapzik when i was back east was saying
like you know what if he didn't kill
them in the jedi temple instead he
[ __ ] said let's just flip all these
kids to the dark side and i was like wow
that'd be like a real for me personally
a decent retcon because that's the one
thing of star part of star wars lore
that
i felt like
wow that went a little
[ __ ] far out there and stuff got real
but mark encountered by saying
no they do that to every [ __ ]
character
like venom becomes an anti-hero [ __ ]
you know raven's about to be an
anti-hero like all of spider-man's
villains are about to be heroes of
movies i don't believe in this lifetime
thanos gonna become come back and be a
good guy as well i mean they did it in
the what if like they may have thanos
the sweetest bartender
exactly so mark's argument was like
let vader vader man like if that's and
he got an excellent point he's like that
wasn't some like you know jj was like
ooh let's make anakin kill all the kids
that was george lucas himself going like
i've gone dark
my money he's killing children like oh
okay
like i guess it is his money but yeah it
was a moment where they could have
retconned all of that and instead they
there's just one apparently
yeah i mean and i think that that
i and jc cannot bump in to tell us fitty
can he can pipe up
but i think the idea was that the empire
had been rounding up force sensitive
children
um and then of those children they made
the third sister fourth brother the
entire inquisitor cadre of agents who
were the most adept force sensitive kids
who've been brought up in the empire in
the system who now have lightsabers but
are not officially jedi yet or sith
because there can be safe
yeah and also yeah i think
the other thing is everybody's like the
rule of two right always two there are
the master and the apprentice well that
was yoda's rule that was never
palpatine's rule that was never vader's
rule they were always pretty
loosey-goosey with that
so i i don't know if darth vader would
continue the tradition
of uh
of the rule of two
i didn't go full evil to obey rules
the um
uh the thing that i really enjoyed with
the last episode or episode
four of obi-wan yeah it's weird hearing
the disembodied video
he's the fourth ghost uh yeah
yeah go go banff ghost
um
was that
riva
put a tracker with leia the third sister
put a tracker with leia which is and
vader's like what are you doing you let
them go which then vader uses that same
trick in a new hope to track the
millennium falcon
and tarkin is like
you know are you sure the homing beacon
on the millennium falcon is is secure
i'm taking an awful risk vader this will
better work and vader's like uh yeah the
uh third sister taught me this ten years
ago yeah he's like i stole this from the
third sister
yeah i mean my my problem
i have i have a few problems with the
way obi-wan has been working out but it
has nothing to do with evan mcgregor who
i remain
incredibly delighted by every time he
shows up on screen like that's a dude
doing a [ __ ] job and he's giving it
his all and
the vader performance is fantastic
although jc did break my heart a little
bit by telling me
that the voice is
not james earl jones of today doing
another vader performance but it is much
like they're doing with luke skywalker
it's a
digital synthesization
amalgamation of every vader performance
put through the computer algorithm and
then spit out to be a new vader
dialogue
it sounded a little fresh to me it
sounds youngish yeah you know waited
especially considering like we heard him
in rogue one and he sounded
oldish yes
recently you know on this show i was
like wow that sounds pretty good but i
figured in a world where they gave mark
his old voice with the same thing i was
like why wouldn't they do that with
young boys why wouldn't they do it here
um
but i there's
especially in episode four
where it was all right so princess leia
has been captured by the empire she's
being held inside of an imperial
fortress and obi-wan kenobi has to mount
a daring rescue with somebody on the
inside who's got to talk to him on comms
who doesn't understand how to put down
cons and talk quietly whatever but
whatever
there's no it sounds familiar it sounds
familiar but there's also there's no
stakes
because we know
both of these people are going to
survive they're not going to kill
obi-wan they're not going to kill late
they're torturing lay for information
that she does not have which is where's
the rebel base ultimately like where the
rebels hiding out how where's the source
of this underground you know
underground railroad to get jedi
children um to safety she knows none of
this so everything that's happening this
episode
kind of doesn't matter in the grand
scheme of things and they don't really
invent a new thing to happen
to take up that slack because yeah
they're going to escape and sure reeve
is probably going to plant some kind of
tracking device because they're not
going to kill him and so she does what
we think she's going to do
and so it leads us through episode 5
which
all of these episodes have these moments
that i do love and episode 5 has a great
moment between obi-wan kenobi and riva
in which she reveals who she is she
reveals that she was a young she reveals
that she was there on order 66 day and
she reveals that that she is not
necessarily a
sort of acolyte of darth vader but she's
there for revenge like she wants to kill
anakin skywalker because she recognized
him because she saw him as he hacked
through the children
you know in fact like he might have even
given he didn't save her
anakin did not save her at all
you know anakin's statement i thought
there was a like
i couldn't kill her and that's why she
my favorite no it was like he stabs her
and then she she says i lie i lay with
the bodies of my dead friends so they
wouldn't notice me
i mean and then yeah
no wonder they put a warning at the head
of this episode yeah
you know and so then they reveal that
okay well riva's out for revenge she
wants to kill anakin skywalker and i'm
like oh that's [ __ ] great what's she
been waiting for
because she's had nothing but like tea
parties with vader
if you told me that it was that vader
had kept himself like secreted away
on his own imperial carrier and nobody
gets to come in there because he's
[ __ ] darth vader he's on mustafar he
never leaves because he's still feeling
himself after
burning up next to a volcano
and the whole idea was how do we draw
vader out into the world how best to do
that
obi-wan kenobi like if i can bring
obi-wan out then i can bring vader out
and then i can kill me
but i mean and spoilers for you there's
a scene where vader's like you are now
the grand inquisitor here's your pin
that i will pin on your chest and if you
really wanted to get close enough to me
to stab me in the face with the
lightsaber you could do it and she
doesn't do it i'm like well then what's
her plan been
what's she been doing
you know
the same thing in episode three like
when when
when you know obi-wan says you remind me
of your mother
you know you have the same look on your
mother's face you know i was like that's
beautiful like the idea that
that leia in still doesn't quite jive
with leia remembering who her mother was
um because she says that in jedi she's
like do you have any memories of your
mother's like yeah i remember her face
she was beautiful and you know she was
always very kind it's like no you've
never met this woman yeah you came out
of her and you were into it
to some other people and you
you'd have to be a
kid with the force in you oh
you are
maybe that maybe his horse babies
have real good facial recognition right
out the chute
yeah
right now luke just happened to look the
other way so he didn't remember what his
mom looked like but she was like oh yeah
she was very pretty yeah like there are
there are emotional moments that i do
really love
um but the the story and the plot kind
of lets me down
um
with
unfortunate regularity and i am still
gonna watch it because it's [ __ ] star
wars then again we've talked about this
ad nauseam that because we are who we
are because we were born when we were
born because star wars is a foundational
memory for us
we are hardwired to respond
to all of this stuff
hoping that it will be great and dealing
with it even if it's not
i'm fine like i like these shows my bar
is so [ __ ] low i guess nobody really
respects my opinion because i just like
everything but like
in chat we got
just uh
stanley goes all star wars shows
have been very disappointing i disagree
i'm not saying like you're wrong stanley
it's a matter of taste but like i found
all of them satisfying where i'm like
can't believe we're getting star wars
shows this is [ __ ] nuts man
um
ash williams says she's an annoying
actress besides obi-wan and vader this
show is unwatchable
i don't know i disagree i think it's
totally watchable like i'm never bored
and sometimes i'm actually excited and
i'm like this is [ __ ] star wars man
yeah i mean i think i think they're
writing
steven bazin in twitter goes leia
basically young sheldon
wow
oh
that one hurt me and i got no skin in
the game whatsoever
like him but ouch could you imagine yeah
but yeah i think that that that moses
ingram who i like as an actress quite a
bit she was fantastic in queen's gambit
um
i just don't think the writing has
helped that character very much
and so all she has to do is give mood
where there's no real foundation for it
you know until you get to episode five
where there's actually a great scene
where it's all about character and it's
all about why she's doing what she's
doing and it's all informed by that but
she's been a bit on an island
by by the text
um and so i don't blame her for that um
do you think yoda shows up
um
the end needs to be i mean if it's
anything other than qui-gon jinn showing
up saying i'm gonna teach you how to be
a blue ghost
it's it's a mistake
it's got to be qui-gon and you have to
get
liam neeson back for that well he's been
saying
qui-gon like you know we're not quite
gone but he's been like trying to reach
out to him in the first few episodes so
i assumed it was a foregone conclusion
that
liam neeson was going to show up but do
you think yoda pops in there
no cause yoda's in isolation on dagobah
i don't think he took his little
spaceship off
how [ __ ] condescending you sound his
little spaceship
look at his little spaceship remember
when [ __ ] grogu was flying the little
spaceship that was adorable
um yeah i guess they're like why would
we show yoda he's old nobody gives a
[ __ ] we're gonna show baby oda from now
on
yeah nut but baby yoda 24 hours a day
seven days a week disney plus is gonna
become the mtv of baby yoda and i'd be
fine with that i would never get tired
of baby yoda ever
i mean do we have to ask you know and jc
i i don't know how you feel about this
but it's the it's it's starting to
emerge the picture of of
of obi-wan kenobi as a jedi
is he's not a very good one
in that
he felt like his one job was to raise
anakin to be a great jedi and he fails
miserably at that
um he's not a particularly good
tactician he's an okay laser swordsman
um he's not a great divorced dad
to luke skywalker um his battlefield
tactics are
woeful
like is he any good at this
is a question i don't think we've ever
asked before because you've always been
like what's [ __ ] obi-wan kenobi like
he's badass look at him he's [ __ ]
obi-wan kenobi yeah maybe he's just one
of those cats that like those who can't
do teach like he knows a lot about the
force but they're like
hey [ __ ] do it and he's like well
the the uh the thing that i see obi-wan
as bamf uh i'm here
invisible um
the thing that i see obi-wan as is he's
like
the best of
like
like a bad church like the jedi didn't
work because they were
too dogmatic and
there's too much hubris which is what
the prequels are all about right is jedi
cannot love
but
luke through love shows
that that's how you save the galaxy
right luke's love for his father brings
his father back and love the thing that
jedi's had to swear off
is the thing that saves the universe in
the end
so
obi-wan was like the high priest of
people saying that love isn't the right
thing so i guess from a certain point of
view he's a great jedi but
also he's a terrible jedi
yeah i mean but i just mean like the
nuts and bolts [ __ ] of like
hey man maybe don't neg this kid who
seems like he's on the edge like
[Laughter]
hey you're doing great anakin instead of
you're a fairly anakin you don't seem to
understand that every time you treat you
want to win too much anakin
so dude just [ __ ] chill
be this is dangerous mine's territory
he's about to be a gangbanger and you
need to be michelle pfeiffer do you know
what he's like he's like um who's the
dude in ted lasso
nate he's nate the great [ __ ] nate
man like
you know qui-gon was his ted lasso he's
a real good coach and for some reason
nate just has to put [ __ ] down in
order to coach and [ __ ] yeah just
[ __ ] just telling us he's a bit of a
wrong communist
i'll tell you right now obi-wan better
park the [ __ ] bus it's that simple
thank you thank you
reach
back to lasso season two for that one
kid
nice job
command z in chat says the star wars
shows have the narrative sophistication
just above old saturday morning cartoons
they look great though
um i would argue that that's what
they're supposed to be you know
like
was it any more sophisticated ever any
more sophisticated than
this is a modern take on you know
[ __ ] buck rogers cliffhangers from
back in the day
isn't that what lucas ultimately
first wanted to do he's like i want to
make flash gordon or buck rogers and
instead he just came up with star wars
or am i just making that up yeah i mean
there's a reason why we call them space
operas right like they're they're
supposed to be these big gigantic
emotional swings
and not necessarily the hard sci-fi of
isaac as an author ray bradbury or some
[ __ ] like that
um yeah
they don't have to be [ __ ] brilliant
they could be totally above this like
right around the same specification of
saturday morning cartoons for me i mean
i don't come to these movies looking for
stories about like the soul and the
human condition i come to
well
they promise you a lot of war in the
stars kids and
to be honest with you it's kind of my
thing has been since i was seven years
old so
every time they put that there man i'm
like i [ __ ] watch this like i never
get
do you think it's an age thing and i'm
not trying to be ageist here and say
like well it's because i
grew up with it but do you think it's
because like
i'm 51 and i'm like are you [ __ ] me
like they're doing a [ __ ] show where
vader is just like
some petty little [ __ ] who [ __ ]
tries to burn obi-wan alive like oh my
god this is my so-called life but in
space like i i i i don't know i feel
very satisfied
by what they're giving me i never feel
like
they should do better i'm like
why when have they like
what's better than this star wars once a
week [ __ ] man
yeah no i used to i get it some people
like quality and [ __ ] oh you know
i'm i'm a quantity man
more star wars is better than
less but better star wars and and i
again i don't even
subscribe to the theory that this is not
good star wars i've enjoyed the [ __ ] out
of myself
my wife you know i keep throwing my wife
in there and stuff but even my wife who
usually hates [ __ ]
was just like this is [ __ ] fun i was
like right like holy [ __ ] who knew
and i was not looking forward to obi-wan
kenobi when they announced it i was like
ugh
now this gives me hope for andor because
i have no hope for a [ __ ] endor
whatsoever
but i you know for my money i'm reverse
of what some people in chat say like
so far
they're [ __ ]
they're they're doing it with the star
wars show as far as i'm concerned
somebody chat said don't apologize like
what you like yes yes but you know i
once
liked the idea that spider-man could
have been wonderful
it took a lot of [ __ ] for that so
bamf
yeah i'll say this about the uh the star
wars today versus the star wars of
40 plus year old people
is that uh
people of our age hold star wars very
precious because
i was like well you get you get one star
wars movie every
three years and then you take a 10-year
break and then you get a star wars movie
not all star wars has to be wonderful
not all star wars has to be for you
star wars
can be there's enough star wars now
there's i mean geez we're going to get
bad batch we're going to get obi-wan
we're going to get andor and then early
in the next 12 you know feb january
february we're going to get more
mandalorian that's more star wars
in the next 12 months
than the three of us had in the first
40 years of our lives you know so like
if you don't like it all
okay don't watch it and then put on the
next show
uh mav in chat says something i find
very interesting you want something you
could watch more than once
that may have historically been true
like
in the 70s 80s 90s but in the era of too
much content
where there's like no time to watch all
the things you want to watch
i'm okay watching something [ __ ] once
you know i don't need it to be like i
got to be able to watch this ten times
i'm more of a scene guy now where it's
like i'm gonna go back and watch that
[ __ ] scene because that scene made me
happy that scene made me [ __ ] cry
whatever [ __ ] any scene that grabs me
emotionally but i'll be honest with you
i don't need to
re-watch a [ __ ] thing the days of
re-watching a thing for me or
it's i can't balance them with the day
of the current era of trying to keep up
with so much [ __ ] content
we grew up in a lovely time where you
could watch caddyshack
[ __ ] 100 times
because
there you didn't have to watch every
episode of the [ __ ] streaming show
that was starting and ending and and
like
you know if you didn't catch up to it
you were gonna left behind it would be
left behind or something like that yeah
that's what summers were for right like
tv took a break
for four months and then you got to just
watch movies either in theaters or on
video and the dream though when tv took
a break like you know we'd always be
like man i wish tv never took a break
and we got what we [ __ ] wished for
and now it's like
how do you keep up drowning in [ __ ]
content
um some folks are still talking about
the lag
that seems to be a youtube thing i don't
know jc how's that going
um
yeah i mean
uh
yes just delay the stream a few seconds
it's all good yeah i'm
i my computer is
is
struggling for whatever reason i'll have
it fixed for next show i'm recording
this
to my hard drive so we can upload the
high quality version later
joey elaine is coming at you hard saying
okay this is just unwatchable with this
lag come on joey
don't lose faith in us
or just watch it tomorrow
when we re-upload just muddle through it
we'll muddle through somehow
we shall um
lightsabers still up
have you seen
the boys yet
no that's another [ __ ] show i haven't
watched it jason muse
just watched season one season two and
the first three or four episodes
of the boys and is now where i was at
the end of season two of the boys where
you gotta wait
he's like how the [ __ ] am i supposed to
watch this every week
like what we can let him stack up if you
want and stuff he goes oh this is so
[ __ ] terrible he's like when i could
watch the whole thing it was amazing
the cry of the binger
um it's particularly good this season so
far i mean better than [ __ ] the last
two seasons i mean
it's it's a little more focused than
season two was i liked the way season
two ended um but the run-up to that was
a little blurry for me
um
but yeah it came out of the gate strong
with maybe the most
disgusting sex scene i've ever seen
um
yeah no it's
it's a like
didn't didn't think we were doing this
on tv ever but we [ __ ] did this on tv
um it makes it makes exploding or
driving a uh a speedboat into a whale
seemed tame
um
and i mean we talked about it the last
couple of years but anthony starr who
plays homelander
is and i put this on twitter the other
day he is giving the best performance
that i've seen on tv this year
because homelander
is frightening and the way it's
frightening and the the the quick
silveriness with which he goes
from
perturbed to pleased to evil to grim
to sardonic
to funny
like and it's like a [ __ ] drop of a
dime this guy is just bouncing between
all of these constellations
um
it's remarkable it reminds me a bit of
tatiana maslany in orphan black which
was a fantastic performance
that was mostly ignored by everybody
gives awards for anything
until i think the last season when it
lost didn't she wind up winning an emmy
she won a golden globe i don't think she
wanted emmy i mean perhaps the internet
will correct me very quickly i remember
she was nominated by things she lost to
like sandra oh or something like that
um
but he's remarkable and he's fantastic
and without him i don't think that show
works nearly as well
um and it's also very clear that at some
point the show needs to come up with an
answer for that
because it's getting as much as i like
him it's all homelander all the time
and so at some point your good guys need
a win
um
and you have to find a way to remove him
from the scene but that's a them problem
i'm just enjoying it as it goes
um
miss marvel
yes let's talk about ms marvel
i am always
i'm gonna tell you right now [ __ ] in
chat n a says kevin's standards are
mcdonald's quality
i would say veggie grill but you're not
wrong
i'm uh
it doesn't take much to satisfy me man
ask my wife that's why we've been
married for like two [ __ ] decades
plus she just looks at it i'm like
so
yeah the bar's real low here kids uh but
you don't need a low bar to appreciate
ms marvel jesus what a charming [ __ ]
show charm city yeah from top to bottom
i saw episode one i've not seen episode
two
it made me uh miss being a teenager
somehow it made me miss being a teenage
girl even though i never was one
um and man oh man it's it's just so
john husey and wonderful
um but even more like it's not just john
hughes it sounds like
kids meditating you know on
existentialism and [ __ ] like it's joyous
the visual
overlay you know what they do with their
graphics
is just so [ __ ]
like fun i saw someplace
compare it to scott pilgrim but i didn't
feel that when i watched it i wasn't
like oh this is very pilgrimate it felt
very fresh and kind of original its own
unique thing these directors
very distinctive style these are the
same cats they're doing back girl
correct i believe you're right [ __ ] man
look at them walking between two worlds
right marvel yeah
this show is [ __ ] charm city as much
as that little girl
um loves
the avengers like that's how much i love
marvel so as i sit there and watch the
show i'm like
there's my character i i too wish that i
could [ __ ] be
one of the gang um what is her name the
girl iman the lion
movie star i mean never mind movie star
just a star absolute star quality pure
joy
exudes pure joy in that performance like
how do you not fall in love with that
character in the show it's it's so
[ __ ] charming it is like i don't i
don't need there to be
a big bad guy
you know what i mean like they're they
they hint at the end of episode one but
like you know there's a couple of
shadowy government agents who are
interested in her and let's go bring her
in or whatever and like they might be a
threat at some point
from what i i've only seen half of
episode two i had to stop watching to
come in podcast tonight um
but if it it could just be
a girl looking figuring out how to
navigate being a teenager
being muslim
being pakistani being a kid from jersey
all of these things while trying to grow
up and date boys and live and live with
their best friend who clearly has a
crush but can't make it happen and
navigating these new powers that are
changing as her body is changing like
that's all enough like i don't
necessarily need there to be a villain
she has to punch in the face by the end
of this i'm sure there will be because
it's a marvel superhero show and we
gotta have somebody to punch but
you know and i'm also very cautious on
judging first episodes um of these
things because i
similarly loved the first episode of
moon night and did not really like the
way and the places that that ended
um so i'm not i'm not gonna
be like this is amazing but it's very
[ __ ] promising
i can't drink at your bar bro it's too
high
got a stool baby i gotta go to
mcdonald's catch a drink cause [ __ ]
[ __ ] what is with you people man
um i don't get it like the people were
like
it's all right my [ __ ] moon night was
on tv
that's all that you don't give a [ __ ]
what the story is there's moon night and
it was oscar isaac one of the greatest
actors on oh god i'm so easy to please
um
but yeah i'm in on miss marvel
right like how [ __ ] sweet is this
show i honestly feel like it's like it's
weird to say because clearly it's made
mostly for kids but
like since she's such a fan of that
world like i
like i get it like i was right there i'm
like holy [ __ ] man like they
they got my number because they're doing
us
and
all superhero stuff is wish fulfillment
i don't need to look at a boy superhero
to still have a sense of wish
fulfillment man or to still be able to
take a journey with a character and
identify with it and be like oh i wish i
was her
um so i'm not divorced from like well
it's a girl so i could never have this
adventure
she's every fan like oh she loves
captain marvel so [ __ ] much
um
but the avenger con
like they better do that in real life
like now that they've established it i
pay cash money to go to that avenger con
instead
um yeah oh it's just [ __ ] lovely and
it looks beautiful
and i you know it's weird like i know
i'm not supposed to i'm a middle-aged
white man and i'm the problem and blah
blah but
you know i i grew up a fat [ __ ] kid
dude and
i know it and a poor fat kid at that and
so i know what it's like to be
excluded and kind of left to the side
and nobody thinks that you'll ever be
the person or anything like that so even
though like it's a story about like a
girl um you know
who doesn't look like me
i i [ __ ]
latched on to the story
right away like i i you know in weird
ways like i identified i mean helps that
it's set in new jersey
although they have a new jersey
convenience store
and
it's not a wawa what you don't [ __ ]
call the king of new jersey convenience
store you know jersey city is only
[ __ ] 45 minutes max from [ __ ]
leonardo and quick stop whatever you
know it's early in the season perhaps
the call is coming there you go
yeah and i think that that
everybody
has been
a bit of a misfit
you know everybody has been
unsure of themselves everybody has been
to your point a little bit on the
outside looking in everybody has a
family who expects things of that
everybody has rituals that they go
through
as part of their religion or their
culture whatever that is even if you're
a [ __ ] polish guy from new york or
even if you're an italian guy from
queens even if you're whatever
the fact that she has her own very
specific
kinds of barriers between her and the
life that she wants that she will have
to learn how to navigate in order to
become the hero she's going to be
is
no different at all than molly ringwald
having to get her parents to remember
it's her [ __ ] birthday like it's the
same [ __ ] it just looks a little
different but functionally it does the
same thing why is she on the outside
looking in and how is she going to find
her way inside or is she going to stop
caring about it and be who she's
supposed to be
you know i just i [ __ ] love it and i
love
i love getting to look into a culture
that i'm not privy to i love i mean the
second episode there's there's lots of
like there's a whole thing about how her
cousin i think is running for you know a
member of the mosque board and so they
go to this big festival and and all of
the little tiny pockets of this in in
this culture and this religion that i
had no access to previously like this is
great
i love it give me more of this give me
more specificity of a thing that i don't
already know i'm with you in that that
was fun for me because it's not my world
so i was like oh nice like somebody here
in chat was talking about
zb says is the halal gap equivalent to
leaving a space for the holy ghost which
is what they would do at
catholic school dances when we were
younger
um
benjamin and chaco's what do you mean
you people because before i was like you
people
how many you people that didn't like
moon night and somebody down here too
who said like they were also like
i didn't like moonlight god there was a
lot of [ __ ] dislike for moon night
i'm telling you i'm easy kids [ __ ] like
sunday morning oh my god have you known
me in high school you just smile at me i
give you a hand job that's how easy i am
say something nice to me and you got my
affection like
make me a show put put moon knight in a
thing i don't give a [ __ ] what the story
is michael
i enjoyed that story i thought that was
a great story
um
all right
yeah before we get into movies ant-man
has a podcast there's another
opportunity for me to
pop up somewhere in the marvel universe
for heaven's sakes
he looks a lot younger than he is it was
it was a line i think in number two
about rudd it was like that's i uh let
me tell you something right now man
let's hurl this message out into the
void
to the great kevin feige
my number ain't changed
down for all cameos
not looking for a job
not looking
direct not as visionary as as the
fella's bringing uh
ms marvel life
but being in miss marvel
it's [ __ ] southern new jersey anyway
there's no reason blunt men and chronic
could not crash their way
into a [ __ ] avengers con this was me
for every season of the sopranos mind
you
come on
new jersey
i'm right here
um before we get into our second sponsor
and the news there was one trailer that
dropped that i didn't want to talk about
um for the sandman
oh
that dropped the same netflix had their
geeked week last week that's where they
announced uh masters the universe season
two which i've turned in all my scripts
for
like you know they waited a long time to
announce it we've been working for a
long time and stuff so it's like i've
seen the first animatics wonderful but
in any event same week they announced
massive universe season two they also
dropped the [ __ ] trailer for the
sandman and
as a kid who bought that off the rack
[ __ ] man yeah [ __ ]
god damn it like that shot
of them [ __ ] calling dream and him
just [ __ ] landing in the binding
circle
hitting so hard gives me chills man
that's [ __ ] it's crazy and then
ending
with the side shot of the corinthian and
just seeing the single blood drop go
down and that's our boy right that's the
most beautiful man in the world it's a
skarsgard isn't it
i'm not sure is that skarsgard ryan i i
think maybe look it up or something like
that i bet your chad will let us know
i think that's
that's the eric the vampire no from
[ __ ] uh
from true blood
let's see
maybe i'm wrong
it sounded like actually but we look
like him in the quarter profile that we
saw
no it's boyd holbrook
oh oh and boyd holbrook is um from
narcos and he was
the bad guy from logan
yes i like him all right i'm happy with
that too i
called it wrong
look
i don't know what to tell you i'm
getting old
look
look they didn't even show me the guy's
face
from his ear i guessed
[ __ ] it was a skarsgard took my shot
he tried your best
i went all in on a scars guard [ __ ]
it's it's an easy thing to do i got
boyded
you got voided nice
that [ __ ] trailer looks magic doesn't
it
oh i can't wait
that is um that's a that right there is
a full advertisement not just for how
wonderful the show is probably going to
be but for like a creator who waits
for the right moment because
poor neil the great gaiman himself
had to kiss a lot of [ __ ] frogs
over the last 30 40 [ __ ] years man 30
plus years
to finally get to a place where they
could make the man the way he wants to
make it and it
he must be god damn
beside himself silly happy
yeah i went to uh these ideas like writ
large so [ __ ] nuts
he had uh he's been he's been on tour
like a sort of speaking reading tour in
an evening with neil gaiman very much
like an evening with with kevin smith
except uh he does more reading and it's
less dirty um
but i went to the one he had in uh in
l.a the ace the theater the ace hotel um
where you've played i came to see you
there once
um
and uh it was lovely i mean it again
it's it's it's him like doing q a but
the queues are already on cards that he
gathered from the audience who's just
reading and answering them as he goes
um and then reading selections of short
stories and snippets and whatever he did
a lovely little batman poem
um
that that uh for in memory of neil adams
which was very sweet
um
but then after it you know i ran into
him at this little sort of meet and
greet after the show was over and he
showed me that trailer
um
about it he's talking for anybody else i
saw before anybody else he was like come
here come here
come here mom i want to show you
something he's got a very proper accent
he's got this right boy come here mate
he's very like he's posh he's less john
constantine for sure but um and he was
so [ __ ] giddy to show it off like
because it's
gorgeous and it's
the thing that the closest that he could
have possibly thought he could get
to what it ought to look like and to see
him so happy about it and to see him so
giddy about it um gave me lots of hope
he's one of the good guys man like you
know this business is full of uh people
that are it's very
high school this business very young
attitudes and young [ __ ] uh
almost childish attitudes my thank you
my love
she's all taken care of
my wife dropping off [ __ ]
liquid death telling me my mom's taken
care of i'm outstanding hi jen
she's oh she yelled hi from the other
people there come on [ __ ] camera but
she yelled died
hmm
what were we just talking about before i
was so [ __ ] rudely interrupted uh
neil gaiman
this [ __ ] guy what a prince i forget
what i was going to say but he's magic
absolute [ __ ] magic i'm so glad
it's happening for him he gets to see
[ __ ] like
you know that shot of [ __ ] the giant
gates
of the dream realm like
must be nuts for him man [ __ ] that he
imagined [ __ ] decades back and now he
gets to see it
come to life in this version and it
looks
like it's gonna be instant classic i
can't wait
august i think
a bunch of
this is that moment where a bunch of new
people are going to discover the sandman
and [ __ ] and you know this always
irritates
some piece of the fan base right where
they're like hey man i like this [ __ ]
before anybody knew about it i mean i
bought issue one off the shelf kid so i
was [ __ ] there
for the birth of the sandman and [ __ ] i
took the ride from the beginning
but i'm happy to have people be a part
of this i'm like yeah more people need
to [ __ ] discover this [ __ ]
yeah and of course the the the
differences in interpretation
of some of these characters will no
doubt piss off some long-time fans why
because
you know we have nice [ __ ] things
mark without understanding somebody off
i don't understand it but the minute you
decide that lucian is not an old white
guy but a young black woman who's the
keeper of dreams library
you know the minute you have
joanna constantine
instead of john constantine it's gonna
piss people off the minute
you know the the the idea that they have
been reinterpreting some of this work
in a way that neil has been at the
forefront of championing
of like yeah no lucifer i'm sorry is
gonna be played by [ __ ] wendell and
christy and not sting
um i'm sorry but it's the way they chose
to go and i as a person who loves those
stories and has love that comic book i'm
thrilled to see a new version of it
that's different what i remember
you know
bring bring me the new i know what it
was
now i want to see what it is they also
announced that uh the great uh the
skeletor himself mark hamill
will be uh playing the role of uh
uh marv pumpkinhead merv pumpkinhood ah
two of you are bonded in one more way
that's true because in the uh podcast
versus the audible version of sandman
the sandman
i
am that character
that means
in the audible version of star wars i
should play luke skywalker
why are you laughing that wasn't a
[ __ ] joke
you think i could see this i think my
dreams are [ __ ] funny
i was gonna go italian station and
pickups and power converters what is
your background
that is um
that is that is
um warner brothers that's chuck jones
i felt like it was very bugs bunny which
which one this is um
[ __ ]
trying to remember the name of it but
it's where daffy duck is robin hood
yeah i can't remember the name of that i
should remember it but
dodge turn parent spin
and books
zoinks in a way
we were a generation raised by looney
tunes and it panned out we're down
i never [ __ ] had an anvil drop on my
head how about you dodged every piano i
saw
um
before we get into q a um we should talk
about our uh our second sponsor of the
evening
uh the good folks at
blue chew
oh yes folks we have another sponsor man
and this [ __ ] is gonna get you excited
dare i say turgid even ooh the
temperatures aren't the only thing
that's rising this summer
that's right
we're sponsored by blue chew oh kids you
know what that blue chew is man that
blue chew heavens
that blue chew
uh that's what you chew
to
do
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com
uh if you use the promo code fatman
you're gonna receive the first month
free
that's bluechew.com for more details
important safety information uh as we're
talking to you about the good folks at
bluetooth man guys
it's time to bring that summer heat into
the bedroom and you know i'm this is
coming from my heart you know i'm
reading this off a script you know i'm
always concerned about whether you're
bringing it in the bedroom you've
watched every episode of fat man beyond
what do i always say mark are they
bringing it in the bedroom
how's your boudoir game strong
well
let's make it stronger because the
temperatures are not the only thing
going to be rising this summer mark
thanks to blue chew indeed it's time to
step up to the plate and that's where
blue chew comes in it's a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them any time day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever the opportunity arises
process is simply you sign up at
bleacher.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved they'll receive your
prescription within days
it's
[ __ ] flawless
simple it's all done online no business
to a doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy with your dick stiffening pills
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package
pop it in your mouth and pop a boner
indeed so if you can benefit from some
extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners it's
try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code fat minute check out just pay
five dollars in shipping that's
bluechew.com
blueechw.com promo code fatman get your
first month for free and visit
bluetooth.com to receive more details
and important safety information and we
thank them for sponsoring this podcast
we do we thank the good folks at blue
chew we haven't seen them in a red hot
minute man
if they do come back and they do believe
in us for heaven's sake so very much so
thank you
blue chew
well done dot com kids
um
all right we're into the second half of
the show hey we should point out that
we're doing this live next week
we are
uh yeah we're going to the cantina kids
and we're going to do a cantina show and
that is uh june 21st june 21st what's up
monday or tuesday that's a tuesday
tuesday so pam you know
oh banff man is
i'll also say
uh there's much less lag when you watch
you guys in person than
uh online
yeah we rarely live when we're in the
continent no yeah it never
never really lags there i mean sometimes
we hit a fog bank yeah and sometimes we
just look at each other and we pretend
lag
yeah just like gaze into your eyes your
eyes are like booze of water your teeth
are like petals on a stream we pretend
to lag and then all of a sudden we'll go
like
and that's why i hate them
like max headroom
yeah like a glitch in the matrix
um okay
uh
news
news
we got some news
is bringing you the news kids he's
[ __ ] comb these here
news fronts
he's gonna bring you the fronts of the
news
and the backs and the backs and the
sides when everything in between give it
up for mark he's bringing in the news
like uh james and the giant peach i've
buried my nose in the news
uh a joker sequel
which had been uh
you know somewhat anticipated given that
the movie made a billion dollars in the
box office
is moving forward
and uh it's a musical
did you see this coming kevin smith
no
could not have but
lady gaga is in early negotiations to
join joker fully ado
as joker's partner in madness harley
quinn
for what would be a musical sequel to
todd phillips's 2019 blockbuster wait
what she's playing
harley quinn
i didn't hear that
yeah
which is surprising given the lock
that margot robbie has on the
live-action iteration of that character
[ __ ] you know he's he's doing his own
thing over there
he's doing his own thing but she's like
matt reeves is doing his own thing if he
does a harley quinn it ain't gonna be
that harly quinn
you never can tell who knows um that's i
did not hear that she would be playing
on [ __ ] no-brainer
movie's gonna make another billion
dollars man
yeah
uh
the speculation that harley quinn
um would appear in the movie first came
after phillips posted a cover the to the
screenplay
on june 7th because the subtitle foley a
dude refers to a shared delusional
disorder
and joker's only real companion besides
batman has been quinn
so it would make some sense
that if it's going to be about delusion
then the two of them would be the
partners in madness so that hasn't been
announced
it hasn't been announced but she is in
negotiations to join the cast as is
joaquin phoenix at this point who his
deal is yet to be settled i mean no but
that hasn't like nobody's saying harley
quinn that's conjecture or that was in
one of the articles um it was in one of
the articles um that she's in
negotiation early negotiations to join
as harley quinn
so that's official wow
i mean it's not not that warner brothers
has said it but like
where's the source is this variety or
the reporter this is hollywood reporter
there you go that's probably pretty damn
official right there they don't get
their [ __ ] that wrong
wow i didn't see that coming at all but
that makes a lot of [ __ ] sense that
movie's gonna make so much money
you know lady gaga who knows it's still
unclear if she's doing any original
music for it or if she's just performing
um but i would have to imagine if you
get lady gaga you get lady gaga write
you a song or two
also a [ __ ] jersey kid if i remember
correctly ooh i didn't know that i think
so i think there was some jersey history
there
um well i'm i was going to see it
regardless i thought he did a wonderful
job on that last joker movie
very
very uh nihilistic mark no don't go in
that movie
looking to come out [ __ ] tap dancing
and feeling good about life
yeah was not not necessarily a feel-good
picture but
absolutely brilliantly made um i look
forward to uh
seeing him do harley quinn wouldn't have
seen that coming
and i don't know why like why couldn't
that come but he just didn't seem like
that guy but i guess he figured out
an angle here
i mean look
you know
it's got elements of king of comedy
right like he had elements of king of
comedy in the last one and
there was like sandra bernhardt's
character was all about the what's his
name's character uh
jerry lewis's character
something like that where she's a
hardcore fan girl that
you know
maybe she isn't maybe she is a doctor
[ __ ] you know what i'm gonna conjecture
i just can't wait to [ __ ] see it
somebody in chat said that was really
high kids i'm 51 there's no such thing
as really high at 51.
not at all oh my god i can go drive a
[ __ ] tractor trailer truck right now
if i needed to i've never done that
before
i
feel like i could
it just makes me really confident at
this point
um benjamin and chat said jokerface lol
cause didn't you think a song called
pokerface indeed that was her first big
hit
uh command z said it before him he said
joe joe joe joker i don't even know how
that song goes god damn it i'm so old i
can't [ __ ] beat these kids at their
own game jokerface is a legit joke and
i'd
pun
the only winning mood kevin is not the
play
uh shiloh store says uh shame on disney
for ditching tim allen for the light
year spin-off by the way i didn't think
that was the case that is not the case
charlotte
the idea was that this is not
buzz lightyear the toy this is buzz
lightyear uh the real guy on which the
toy was based i thought we had this
discussion we did it seems as if shiloh
just wants to be
allegedly an [ __ ] alex phillips said
joker two foley akash you ain't kidding
they're gonna kill you aid
everyone's gonna get paid and it's gonna
make a lot of money but you know what
this is this is what you pay for man
like this is the kind of thing where i'm
like take my money that sounds like a
good idea
is it ready my only complaint is is is
it ready to be watched
uh the folks in chat were asking about
clerk's three
yeah
we were talking about motion pictures uh
i believe you'll be seeing a trailer uh
early in july perhaps
yes i've seen the posters they're
wonderful i saw the trailer it's
fantastic i was delighted that like
i had
one and a half note on the trailer and
it wasn't like
a long note it was like can we flip
these shots um
yeah it's they they nailed it i was very
impressed you know when you're a
filmmaker
you dream of the trailer because at the
heart of every filmmaker is just you
know a kid who loved movies and
[ __ ] trailers or what we called
coming attractions back in the day
just as powerful as the [ __ ] feature
itself and it's an art form that belongs
to an editorial elite few
um i consider myself an editor but i'm
an editor of my own work and even as an
editor of my own work i don't think i
could distill a movie in two minutes and
make me excited about it without you
know [ __ ] making me go like wait
you're missing this you're missing this
and they put together a trailer i was
like look if you don't like that [ __ ]
trailer skip the movie because that
that's that's the [ __ ] movie right
there like distilled without you know
without the ending and [ __ ] so i i look
forward to people seeing it it's coming
soon anyway back to mark with the news
uh
and this week
in ezra miller miller is apparently an
[ __ ]
um the flash star uh deleted their
instagram account after posting a
variety of memes taunting authorities
who are actively searching for the actor
after they were accused of manipulating
and grooming an underage fan
um
this guy's less a superhero and sounded
more and more like a super villain man
like this is i'm sorry they are sounding
uh less and less like a superhero and
more and more like a super villain um
yeah no wonder why does warner brothers
go like
i mean i do i don't i don't [ __ ] know
but like miller is reportedly hiding
from law enforcement officers after
chase iron eyes and sarah jumping eagle
were granted a protective order against
the flash star on behalf of their 18
year old child
takata ironized the couple alleges that
the actor took advantage of their child
since takada was 12 years old
engaging in cult-like and
psychologically manipulative controlling
behavior ironized and german eagle have
stated that miller provided their child
with access to alcohol and drugs
um
on the to counter that takata has since
defended miller claiming that their
father is transphobic in a message that
he posted to instagram
um but the chase ironized and sarah
germain eagle cast doubt on the
legitimacy of the statement revealing
that japan does not have a phone
um
and so yes miller has been
apparently the memes that he's used to
taunt their legal officials who are
pursuing the actor feature texts such as
you cannot touch me i'm in another
universe
and message from another dimension
and the longest of the five messages
reads i'm shielded from negative people
and their ill intent my spirit mind body
soul and success are not
altered by anyone's envy i am protected
from all negative something people
attempt to throw at me subconsciously
and consciously i clear any and all
hidden piers for hidden enemies
i i
i i don't know
what warner brothers
attempts to try to do
to salvage the flash movie
which again of all of this that is the
least of the concerns which is you know
allegedly
um miller does not seem to be the nicest
guy and has done a series of not great
things
to fans and children and
people he's been staying with to the
point where he's been arrested on
numerous occasions and restraining
orders filed
um
but yeah one of this is a giant 200
million dollar movie centered around
this guy sorry this actor um
that
if we're to come out tomorrow
i feel like it's somewhat unreleasable
and it's not as if they didn't know
that he had some issues under his belt
their belt
um
because there was the allegations and
video
of miller choking out a fan before they
even started shooting a movie i thought
that video came out right yeah that
video was
before they start shooting this flash
movie he ran a flash a few times
somebody pointed out they've been trying
to make this movie
where they announced this movie
back when season one of the flash tv
show started
yeah announced ezra miller as flash was
that accurate
um i i don't think it's as early as
season one because i remember the
conversation that we had
was grant gustin is the flash to
vast swabs of the world
you know warner brothers spent
millions of dollars advertising him and
teaching an audience that this guy is
the flash and so to then put a different
person in the films seems counter
intuitive to how you're spending this
money
and definitely contrast to marvel's idea
that everything is the same story
and so if you're going to put the hulk
in a tv show the hulk had better be
played by mark ruffalo
otherwise don't put him in your tv show
and so there was a chance for them to
replace ezra miller with gran gustin
before they started shooting flashpoint
but they stuck with the guns that had
been set forth by zack snyder who cast
him in justice league
and now they're reaping the
[ __ ] whirlwind
i am uh sorry to sidetrack this but
gavin gardner just pointed out in chat
that poker face
came out 14 years ago so it's not even a
current reference
no and
i couldn't even muster that
you tried that
yeah my my uh yeah i was praising the
person that made the poker face joke but
this cat pointed out bro that's
the song's like 14 [ __ ] years old
it's not even a finger on the pulse you
kids you kids today in your music
joke oh my god i'm getting sold still
people complaining about the lag uh kids
uh jc apologizes he has some
issues but we suggest just uh re-uh
refreshing they're also saying
if you pause for 15 seconds
and then hit play
that the lag goes away
oh there's another subject
see if you pause the feed
for 15 seconds and then let it play the
lag will go away
um or you can go away i've seen a lot of
people go like i can't take this and
they've bolted and stuff i feel you
i feel you it really sucks when
something that's free doesn't work the
way you want it to but
as uh said by jc earlier it'll be up
tomorrow yeah it's pristine copy
tolerate this [ __ ] [ __ ] all over
again
where'd you
go afterwards anyway i mean there's
generally like only a few thousand
watching when we stream and then
like they catch up later on man last
episodes i saw was up to like 117 000
views
on my town
on youtube here on youtube that doesn't
even count the
the
uh facebook feed
i'm sure some people like expect a
higher number i'm very satisfied with
that number we are two middle-aged men
talking about work that's not
ours there is no
good reason why anybody should watch
this show let alone
the the the many people that do so thank
you for those that tune in
or you can buy tickets to see us all
live in person next tuesday
where can they get the ticket csmod.com
or you can go to eventbrite and look it
up right
i've got the uh the url is on your
screen so you can type in
fatman621.eventbrite.com
come see us live my mom is going to be
there
yes fill this place up man my mom's
going to get drunk on blue milk
outstanding [ __ ] [ __ ] face wasted
[ __ ] hit on the club owner and [ __ ]
and i will say that you know there's
some [ __ ] to give away that we've been
hoarding
that might end up going
yeah we got given some cool things to
give out which is
pretty impressive um look we always give
out cool [ __ ] you always get 40x tickets
and stuff
um which apparently top gun is the movie
to see in 40x right now
uh or screenx tickets which like elvis
is coming out and screen next i'm going
to be taking my mom to see that
bless brett deacon and stuff
so we always have cool 40x and screenx
tickets to give out but we might have
some extra special [ __ ] to give out this
week kids in fact i know we do
indeed june 21st right there at uh scum
and villainy canteen on hollywood
boulevard in hollywood california
you'll find hollywood mark bernardin and
hollywood kevin smith and a non-laggy
banff man indeed
uh so back to the news marvel
has got a thunderbolts movie a bruin
um marvel studios top secret
thunderbolts movie is looking to have
gained momentum um now that they've got
a director a fellow named jake schreier
who's on board to pen the new marvel
tent pole
the black widow writer eric pearson is
writing the script and of course kevin
feige is producing
what is it called thunderbolts
thunderbolts yep
it revolves around a group of
supervillains or at least characters who
played bad guys at one point in the mcu
who go on missions for the government
um in the comics that have been sort of
headed up by a general thunderbolt ross
hence the name thunderbolts
um but it seems as if potentially the
julia louis-dreyfus character
the contessa de la fontaine i believe
who we first meet in a in falcon and
winter soldier
might be
the woman heading up the thunderbolts
this go-round
um william hurt passed away right so he
did he can't be the guy he did but it
feels as if perhaps you have characters
like baron zemo
um elena belova
ghost task master the abomination us
agent
and the winter soldier if you wanted it
i love this i love this
i love this
love it
um in the comics wasn't it like when
they started like nobody revealed they
were bad guys until a couple issues in
if i remember correctly yeah
yeah i mean i think it's got a little
bit of the same spirit of suicide squad
which is you know send a bunch of bad
guys out to do things because nobody
cares what happens to them um but if
there's a if there's a world in which
you can play it a little undercover if
you can play it as it's a culmination of
a storyline you've been watching
um in tv shows and movies up until it
comes out that's also super fun
so yeah there's no date on that yet
but it's in the works
chickenmonkey33 said they announced the
ezra miller in the standalone flash
movie all the way back in 2014. so not
10 years ago but
eight years ago
um
you think that do you think eventually
warner brothers is just like
we gotta we gotta we gotta walk away we
gotta
i mean i think that barring a uh
a very expensive
um reshoot
to drop grant gustin in sort of
tygnataro style
in in this movie
which is ultimately just making a
different movie
um there's a version of this story that
ends with the flash movie not being
theatrical at all
um that it goes to hbo max it just sort
of gets
quietly released
um to satisfy contractual obligations
but
you know i don't know how you mount
a giant press campaign for this movie
and
either put ezra miller out there to talk
to journalists or don't have them out
there at all and somehow talk around the
fact that
said performer
seems to be
all kinds of trouble
watch the flash run from the cops
night
um speed force measure
this is pete
very good
uh what are the news stories we got
there mr mark bernardin um let's see
deadpool 3 will still be deadpool even
in the mcu
um
the forthcoming deadpool 3 marks the
first time the franchise will be
produced after disney bought 20th
century fox
and some fans have expressed concern
that the r-rated merc with a mouth might
just become another kid-friendly
jokester under new ownership but the
screenwriters um who've done
their one-end deadpool tool rhett reese
and paul wernick
um ease those fears in a recent
interview with den of geek
um paul wernick who said deadpool is
going to be deadpool
um
it's a thrill uh rhett reid said about
the merger
it's an absolute thrill to have the band
back together to have a new backdrop in
the mc with new characters new villains
and that sort of thing you know it's
never a marriage we necessarily saw
coming fox and disney that was an
external thing apart from our
storytelling process but we're finding
absolutely that there's a serendipity
and gold in that situation
um
and disney has apparently been very
supportive with regard
to uh to both taking other marvel
franchises and pushing the envelope with
the humor
um and when it comes to a particular
joke if they cross the line maybe we'll
hear about it at some point you know
maybe not that joke but they've been
incredibly supportive of where they're
going because we're obviously doing it
separate from them for a long time
um
so yeah deadpool is going to be rated
deadpool's going to go for it um and who
knows what characters they'll be able to
fold in but they had did not have access
to the last couple of times
um i'm ready and i'm just happy to hear
that they're not gonna try to like
beverly hulk's cop three it
when they
[ __ ] released a pg-13 beverly hills
cop movie and you were like
yeah
i mean i was in a pg-13 die-hard movie
and he didn't get to say
yipikaya [ __ ]
somehow
on purpose that was the whole thing
though like we can't say [ __ ] in
a pg-13 movie so
wow something will have to prevent him
from saying the line
um are you a what we do in the shadows
fan
uh i'm not a non-fan i just haven't
watched it ever my kid absolutely loves
it
um i think i think you would dig it my
kid says that all the time she was like
i i don't know why you're not watching
this she's like you would absolutely
[ __ ] love this i was like i'm gonna
get to it let me get to it life is long
kiddo life is long um well if you make
it through the first four seasons which
you've already aired um be
be satisfied in the fact that it's been
renewed for seasons five and six
on fx
um so they will know there will be no
dearth
of the uh of the staten island vampire
clan
um in your life should it be a thing
that you choose you want
um
let's see
the best batman kevin conroy had a story
in the uh in the new dc pride 2022 i saw
that got a lot of attention got a lot of
attention um because the legendary
batman voice actor kevin conroy uh tells
a very touching and personal story about
coming out as gay
in one of what has been dubbed one of
the most important dc comic stories in
years in dc pride 2022 number one
um
and he talks very much about
you know
the story is called finding batman um
that he tells alongside artist jay bone
and letter adida
carr and he talks about how finding
batman was a turning point in his life
and identity and he admits to putting
his own mask to putting on his own mask
growing up in a devoutly christian
troubled family hiding that he was gay
in his public life for decades
um he recounts living through the hiv
aids epidemic in the 80s
and being called slurs by fellow actors
and producers and he struggled with
doubts about himself and his career for
decades until getting a call about a
voice role for batman the animated
series
um
it is a beautiful story like i picked up
the the issue over the weekend um your
friend in mind danny fernandez has a
story in there a sort of harley quinn
poison ivy romance piece that's just
lovely um
but then reading this this story as well
like it's
it's what
it is what comics has the power to do
which is it lets you tell
very personal stories um under the guise
of or helping use characters who we know
and love as avatars for that growth and
to a certain degree that pain i mean
pauldini did it previously when he
talked about his
journey after having been violently
assaulted on the streets of manhattan
and how batman was i think the streets
out here not me she was out here i'm
sorry my bad um but
beverly hills if i remember beverly
hills um and how batman was very crucial
in his path to recovery um
and it seems as if the dark knight has
that ability to be
that sort of
figurehead
of both pain
and triumphing over that pain he's a
band-aid for a lot of bruises old batman
he's uh good for what ails anybody and
uh can be an avatar for
most so long as you're always trying to
do the right thing
kevin conroy is the batman kids like
that's who i hear when i read comics
whenever i read batman i hear kevin
conroy speaking he is the voice of
batman
lovely
damn human being man
one of my favorite things i've ever done
in this lifetime is
he's got a little cameo and
yoga hosers not the greatest of movies
but
he says something to the girls and he's
standing next to like a shorter younger
kid and at the end of it he goes come on
robin and then they leave
um i love kevin he's so awesome i saw
him trending this week and getting
loads of attention for that story um
very very cool
yeah
um
and finally before we close the the news
bulletin for the week
it's a little
not quite nerd news but you know we love
it so [ __ ] it we'll talk about it
ted lasso season 3
is most likely going to be the final
season of ted lasso now
yeah look dan i
i it's better to have loved and lost
than to never have
loved it all or to borrow from that show
believe
believe there'll be a season four and
five uh and if there's not
i'm just happy we got what we got like
i'm okay with their decision to
stick to three um
you know
i loved one and two and also
let them go away for a few years they'll
come back maybe do a reunion movie or a
reunion series or something but
you know why
yeah i thought about it when i first
read that because it was a brett
goldstein said
yeah he said they're writing season
three like it's the last
you know and i was like well wait a
second but like there's
not much left for him to do as a
character out there and do you really
want to watch seasons four five and six
of like
he's still the nicest guy in the premier
league you know good old [ __ ] ted
like so trust they know what they're
doing that show is so [ __ ] brilliant
if that crew is like we're done after
this season i'm like
go with god go with smod i say and keep
going
um
magical goddamn show
um somebody in chat asked about the uh
predator prequel trailer prey did you
see that i did
who knew that was a [ __ ] movie who
knew that was a like did anyone what
do you know this was coming i knew it
was coming because um one of the guys
that i worked with on treadstone a guy
named patrick ayson is writing the
screenplay or has written the screenplay
it's a movie correct it's a movie um
that's premiering on hulu
um and not theaters why
unclear
this [ __ ] looked [ __ ] dope i mean
look i'm talking about not going to see
top gun two in a theater and like
everyone's like you have to but that
prey trailer i'd [ __ ] go see that in
the movie theater yeah this is this is
them going back to the past like maybe
the do i read this correctly this is the
first predator come to earth
um i don't know if it's the first
predator to come to earth but it's
definitely a story about
predator and the conflict with some
first nations um hunters
and it seems to be about period right
like
like it's you know i don't know what
year it is but
you know it at least seems to be at a
time when
there is a colonial presence because i
think you do see in that trailer they're
baskets and some muskets and the
predators sort of getting down killing
some [ __ ] colonists
wasn't there i have vague memories maybe
in one or two like at one point you look
in the ship and you saw some like
trinkets from like
different girls and [ __ ]
was that my dream that yeah in predator
2 there's a scene where danny glover
ends up in the predator's mothership and
then you see a bunch of like trophies
and [ __ ] on the wall
one of which is also the alien skull
which i remember was the giant
the predator versus alien and then we
would get 19 predator versus alien
movies
but yeah the idea that the predator had
been visiting or that that species has
been visiting earth
for centuries and using it as some kind
of training ground
um
was was always really intoxicating and
so to get to see like apocalypto meets
[ __ ] predator
we got
excellent reference good poll
um we got our end game in predator 2.
when they showed [ __ ] the aliens
calling the predator like in the same
movie not the same frame that was our
[ __ ] end game way more so [ __ ]
cheap like literally you just you just
had to like a still picture of two
things that had never been in a movie
together
is enough to make
a young boy just lose his [ __ ] mind
oh my god it's the equivalent of like
just blow on it don't you don't even
have to just look at it please
please i've been in prison for three
years my dick gets hard when the wind
blows
um
yeah man that trailer looks [ __ ] good
yeah good as hell
i think that's also in august maybe
august is a big [ __ ] month for nerd
[ __ ]
uh i'm seeing i don't want to call jc
into things because it'll create a lag
for some people but i'm seeing a few
deleted messages by jc and chad i guess
some people are being
shitty what i have no idea jc is being
the the cop
black adam trailer did we get to talk
about that i think we did last time
uh pray uh sixto reynoso says pray is
set during the french indian
wars i mean this is a good idea how come
they have they ever time traveled with
the show not time travel but have they
ever like
done predator back in the day or is it
always like predator now
predator in the future is this the first
time they've been like predator then
um
i don't i don't know i didn't see robert
rodriguez's predators
and so but i feel like that was still
mercenaries with guns just in a
different jungle
um
and the predator that shane black did
was very contemporary it was very just
like again guys with guns trying to
shoot a predator and failing at it can
you
do predator in world war ii or is that
in bad taste i mean tarantino killed
[ __ ] hitler in a movie and everyone
loved that so
can you do predator
versus
watch it
i mean i [ __ ] watch it too but i mean
is that gonna offend somebody and [ __ ] i
don't think so i mean didn't the bad
robot do a movie called overlord
which was about the sort of nazi sort of
occult experiments that created a whole
[ __ ] ton of werewolves and
then it's like killing [ __ ] nazi
werewolves here for that
you know hellboy took place
chunks of it in the in the 40s
um
can i uh tell you what great fans we
have you know kids i always shout out to
like uh
the negative [ __ ] there are tons and
tons of lovely comments in chat but
um
this cat wrote the dork knight i don't
know when he came in but he came in late
he just wrote
kenobi is trash did they show for it
like he literally just walked into the
party
like just [ __ ]
wanting to talk about how bad kenobi is
trash and then wanting to know
since it came late have we already
shield for it
nice
oh my god you had a [ __ ] like a
thing
i'm an old man who almost died four
years ago i just want to like things in
life
pick them apart and be shitty about him
i don't [ __ ]
god life is short kids
anyway what else with that um that's all
the news
oh thank the lord man all the news given
us given to us by
mr mark bernard give it up for mr mark
bernard a new sound through and through
um we started talking about the black
adam trailer
um which
i i liked because i like dwayne johnson
but that is again like i am 100 sure
that by the end of that movie black adam
is going to be a hero
oh of course of course but
i don't know if you heard [ __ ] kent
nelson aka doctor
[ __ ] say he had a vision
that this guy would either save the
world or destroy it or destroy this
world or save it
something tells me
i mean look [ __ ] they could go all
george lucas with the younglings and at
the end he just punches the earth in
half it splits everybody dies screaming
and
he sits on a rock throne and they're
like credits
could make [ __ ] five billion dollars
people like that's a bleakest most
honest superhero movie i ever saw
and that's shazam has to fight him in
the sequel to that movie i loved seeing
uh hawkman i loved seeing dr fate like
you know uh you know the other guy adam
whatever
but yeah i'm i'm there
showed it's in muse and he was like
[Music]
this is like after it had been out for a
week i'm like
how do you not [ __ ] hear about this
he was like i hear the [ __ ]
rocks making
black adam i was like he's been making
it for like a decade
trying as long as ezra miller was
passing the flash
has
that's what's going to happen he's
[ __ ] they're going to be on the flash
sequel he's going to be like did you
ever hear what that kid ezra miller did
it's like
yes back when it happened yeah
um you know what uh we should talk about
very quickly uh yes sir oh uh
the end of uh the most recent season of
barry um i said it earlier in this uh
you know on an earlier
episode bill hader is a [ __ ]
fantastic director this guy's gonna win
an oscar one day not that that should be
the gold standard but this [ __ ]
breathes and thinks
film i saw him in a video [ __ ] uh
reference jacques tati
deep cuts man this kind of guy that like
knows eric romer
knows his work not through richard
linklater liking it but because he's
like oh i've watched all the films of
eric romer this guy's true film man that
was an insanely well-directed show all
of his episodes just have beautiful
composition
um
you know and he does let storytelling
just happen in the background of shots
he's not
like uh mr coverage i mean you know
there's definitely coverage but like
got some gorgeous wides on that shotgun
[ __ ] knows how to direct man i'm
telling you that dude wins an oscar
within the next [ __ ] five to ten
years maybe even shorter
i've never seen barry and i know that i
should rectify that really good man
[ __ ] henry winkler's grading it he's
great whole cast is [ __ ] great
but i appreciate and it's it reminds me
steven root is i mean astounding the guy
who plays noho hank that guy's brilliant
like
sally this is great [ __ ] cast
customers back to you sir but i just i
appreciate it in the same way that i
appreciate what neil gaiman did with the
sandman
which was
for as good as any specific story may or
may not be
the invention of the framework to be
able to hold any story he wants to tell
you know like
barry is a way for for bill hader to
exercise every cinematic demon that he
has to tell every kind of story that he
wants to tell he wants to be funny he
wants to be serious wants to have action
and explosions and all kinds of [ __ ]
like he was a show that lets him do all
of it
whereas sandman is is a story
is a is a basin
that neil could fill in any given
episode any given issue with i want to
do shakespeare and i want to do harder
and i want to do serial killers and i
want to do cosmic you know [ __ ]
adventures i don't want to do religion
and i want to do you know trans heroes i
want to do contemporary and period and
future and all of it
there was nothing he couldn't do within
that book and it still felt like that
book and i just i i always admire when
somebody you know stakes for themselves
the menagerie with which they want to
play
and then just gets to do it to their
hearts content like i think that's
that's really admirable and noble and
the fact that there's a giant
corporation and it's like yeah they go
for it
watch it dude it's uh no i'm not watch
it dude i'm saying barry
watch your step
it's if
for nothing i mean there's a laugh out
loud funny [ __ ] and his performance is
wonderful but like
just to see
like
wonderful direction on display
um
you know and maybe some people would
argue that like hey man if you're
noticing the directing then it's [ __ ]
not one of [ __ ] like every episode
i'm like
this [ __ ] guy
like makes it look like goddamn cinema
every week is beautiful it's worth your
time um all right
uh how do we do this banff man without
creating lots of lag and stuff some
people have been saying
uh to skip the lag
they go back four minutes and then
there's no lag whatsoever because the
stream is way ahead of them but we need
banff man to give us some questions
otherwise we don't get to do the q a
part of the show kids so we can still
type in it just can't ban fans even when
he's been talking people have been like
oh god it's lagging
yeah that's not they're not that's not
right because whether
nothing changes like i'm not punching
any buttons i'm just being quiet
so if it's the sound of my voice that's
causing the lag but then i need to
become a weird superhero
look i've always said you need to become
a weird superhero i don't know i'm glad
you're agreeing with me even though it's
for a different reason but
i've got some good questions tonight
though
oh okay
uh
casey jones said um
was the son of a [ __ ]
uh if you could book a tour in the star
wars universe
what planet or location
would you most like to visit
hoth
i'm a liars guy i can wear that silent
bob coat on hoth and not sweat and [ __ ]
i am not going to tatooine
i grew up next up i grew up next to the
goddamn gateway national park i didn't
go to the beach that much you think i
want to go to tatooine you're acting
mine i ain't going to the casino planet
from the ryan movie ryan johnson movie
we got vegas i could jump on a southwest
flight
because i fit these days
i fit back then too for the record um
you know where else they got dagobah
i ain't going no swampy area and [ __ ]
like that that's why they got alligators
that's how you get alligator or worse
i'm going in that booth
now naboo is ultimately just the [ __ ]
amalfi coast
and like i just want to go hang out like
buy some lake and eat grapes and you
know there's there's no sand anywhere
apparently that gets in your skin it
gets everywhere the sand is everywhere
padma
padme amidala
i mean [ __ ] at some point the guy who
created all the star wars [ __ ] was
like all right i'm revisiting my world
after years and [ __ ] and this is a kid
who grew up on tattooing and he probably
hates sand i'm gonna write some [ __ ]
about sam and he's been taking [ __ ] for
it for the last [ __ ] decade and a
half if not longer
two decades sand it's so coarse and gets
out everywhere
look it's like i tried to be relatable
and these [ __ ] people he might be the
first like uh victim of like fandom that
turned on him and stuff like that i
remember so weird watching people be
like what does this george lucas guy
know about star wars and you're like uh
a lot
yeah
yeah like i one of my favorite things to
do is to see
people on the internet
try to go hard at the guys who created
stuff without knowing it so it's like
well what is like neil gaiman i would
like you to explain how neil gaiman
could possibly turn this character in
from a man to a woman it's like well
because we
auditioned people and she was the best
it's like you don't know anything about
sandman it's like well i think i do
and that's it
you know like i just i love it it's like
oh it's so jeff's kiss when somebody
tries to climb the mountain
and get slapped down by facts
um he goes naboo kids which is like you
know [ __ ] wow prequel trilogies
yeah well you know it was less it was
less basic hot slash cold slash wet
which is a lot of what i'm still
sticking in half it's [ __ ] you know
it's chilly
got you could ride a ton ton i won't
even get on a horse i don't know what
the [ __ ] i would be interested in riding
a town town for
uh what about what about endor
you close [ __ ] doors and your buddy's
like
it's always sad that they close the
doors on you and [ __ ] wampas you ain't
got to [ __ ] with them but they're out
there you know you can see them with
your binocs and [ __ ]
none of these seem like
an endorsement for uh for [ __ ] hoth
and there's like a vacation spot
everything's trying to kill you king if
you're into that kind of [ __ ] i'm not
but like some people are into that
tobogganing tubing
everything you've said is if you're into
that sort of thing i don't do it but
if you like taunton slavski that door's
not bad but those ewoks were kind of
vicious man and just because they became
friends with like you know lou khan and
leia doesn't mean they're gonna become
friends with you and [ __ ] they could be
like one of them uncontacted [ __ ]
peoples where you show up on their
island they will [ __ ] kill you man
i mean that's fair but like to your
point you can still wear a coat
it still it gets cold enough at night
and maybe even during the day that you
can you can have a good coat
i mean i like
indoor don't impress me i grew up near
pine barrens like
i i'm gonna go with uh alderaan which we
saw in kenobi
alderaan looked divine with some
mountains and forests palaces
in any timeline knowing eventually
it gets blown out of the sky but it did
look pretty dope didn't it
well the forests are full of fleas so
you may want to avoid that yeah there
you go
you got it
not man
it wouldn't go there either bad [ __ ]
happens there
no
oh oh [ __ ] i know where i go for a
vacation
you truly belong with us here amongst
the clouds i go to bespin [ __ ]
all right
[ __ ] hang out with lobot
i'm a boy yeah that's where you take
your lady on an anniversary weekend away
you have an exit bed that is like caked
in old [ __ ] semen man you just put
your black light on there
you gonna turn on your [ __ ]
lightsaber and hold it over the bed you
just need
jizz from many galaxies
look like that [ __ ] star field when
they make the jump to hyperspace and
[ __ ]
um all right jc i think we answered
sufficiently i think
in the pores that happened on this
mattress
millions of protocols cried out
are you guys stranger things people
uh i've
not seen it
i saw the first episode of this current
season um but i have not binged all of
it so a little out of that loop so games
unhinged uh says in the spirit of
stranger things season four
uh what song would save you from vecna
and why
meaning i don't know if you've seen the
kate bush's running up that hill is like
everywhere now it's the number one song
i guess stranger things used it to
help this person escape from vecna
uh what would your guys songs be your
your uh s
song to help you get through a
tough
intergalactic demonic time
he says i would assume kevins would be
something elvis
look
i may know a lot about elvis that i've
forgotten since i went to graceland with
my mother [ __ ] months ago
but no i would i wouldn't pick that i i
think i would pick
be tempted to pick almost any early run
dmc song because they're so [ __ ]
positive
i'll go i think mine would be hearts on
fire from rocky iv
[Music]
i mean that song comes on i feel like i
could like outrun a cheetah
that's true good point [ __ ] paul i
forgot about that
um
hmm
oh i [ __ ] know
you got it
oh it's the song that makes everybody
want to keep going forward
ain't nothing going to break in my
stride ain't gonna
hold me down oh no no
you've got to keep on moving chris cross
it would be uh here man my [ __ ] you know
what song drives me when i'm like i got
to get up that [ __ ] hill
master of puppets and pulling your
strings
in your mind i've never done cocaine in
my life but i love a song about cocaine
makes me wanna
makes me wanna get [ __ ] done i don't
know i don't know if i can answer this
question properly
uh i am choosing um
billy oceans get out of my dreams get
into my car
wow
which feels like it's an appropriate
anthem
for
uh
dispatching with potentially
cerebral based demonsio
on on chat said run dmc rock box 100
agree that's that would be an anthem i
would totally use
we got all the rhymes and all the time
we don't drop time we don't do crime we
bake a little cake with duncan hine
never wear the clothing like calvin
klein because calvin klein's no friend
of mine
want nobody's name on my behind
lee on my leg
sneakers on my feet
d by my side and j with the beat my god
they just broke down
the [ __ ] simple formula for living a
happy life
just what am i wearing who am i standing
with
yes
and who is keeping the beat who's
keeping the beat
the only things you needed to know back
then kids now it's a way more complex
world
i
threw our hands in the air and we waved
them like we didn't care yeah like you
want a rap just look around you and say
it in a way that rhymes
i never i'll never forget on
dogma chris rock and i would
bond it over like a repeated running
joke of
the run dmc lyric um
now the things i do make me a star and
you could be too if you know who you are
just put your mind to it you go real far
and there's two versions
the one we would always pick on is the
one that was like and the next thing you
know you'll have a big car and you're
like
perhaps one more drafty one more draft
and uh i believe it also became like the
pedal to the metal while you're driving
a car
it switched up a few things but then you
know
the next thing you know you'll have a
big car
like that was both rock and i were just
like
that's it that's the top of the mountain
like
outstanding yes
and then he took me to see run dmc
oh yeah in the city it tracks
like i could have [ __ ] thrown a
tissue at them and broken their arms we
were so close
uh and you know that was me long before
that was when there was all three of
them were together no
yeah
there's a guy who used to wear one of
those did you have one of those mdmc
sweatshirts with the big puffy letters
mark the sleeves and [ __ ] i did not i
had i had the black denim
uh jackets in the black denim
pants
and the and the shell top adidas but i
never had the big puppy
never puffed
loved it still love it so one of my
favorite pieces of clothing i ever wore
in my life i wore that [ __ ] to death you
know i wear that purple coat everywhere
and people like stop it
i wouldn't run dmz shirt until it was
threads man until people saw my like fat
moves and nipples hanging out and
they're hooking up
enough it might be time to bring it back
man i'm sure you can find that [ __ ] on
ebay gotta be i i've you don't think
i've looked over the course of the last
20 years periodically i will surf and
look for it and stuff
um you know a vintage one a real one
god blessed very expensive a lot of
knockoffs
you've got how you're finding out people
are finding out my secret passions like
what do you think kevin smith does at
three in the morning
dude
put some of that tiffany money into a
run dmc sweatshirt yes my mom gets
earrings i try to find me a run dmc
sweatshirt that reminds me of one i had
when i was oh 15 years old that's bad
how expensive
jc
that was a question bring us
the third
second
right did we do two already we did two
uh yeah we did right vacation spot song
uh the last one in honor of uh mark's
son's graduation
uh jeffrey craig asks uh what graduation
gift would the rest of the avengers get
spider-man for his graduation
oh wow hmm
what a great question all right
iron man gives him an upgraded suit
that's his thing
maybe he's dead but he had one built
thor
lets him try to lift the hammer nice
um cause you know all the avengers got
to do it but peter wasn't an avenger
then
um
hawkeye
like while he's real drunk admits that
he's super jealous of how everyone loves
peter even though
he's brand new to the team and
went around for a while and even had his
own mini series
what am i doing wrong a drunk hawkeye
says to peter parker who
is raised too politely to you know put
it on front street and he's just like
everyone loves you man
this is why they're not letting me near
the marvel movies they're like that
sucked um
black widow
she's like didn't i give enough
must i also get him a graduation gift i
only died to save the [ __ ] world you
pricks
um
hulk
hulk gives him a pinata
which he then smashes himself
it's a self-serving gift
um
captain america
gives uh peter parker subway pass
there are a couple of new yorkers so he
understands what the most valuable gift
is
the gift of
transformation i guess spider-man can
swing around you don't need a subway
does it
but he's raised too polite to say
anything to cap about it right
so cap gets to think that he gave him
the ultimate [ __ ] gift and [ __ ]
there you go there's my avengers one
shot what about you mark
um
i do like
tony having
because i think you have to play tony as
being
not with us anymore same with black
widow
um
but tony having left a present for him
um
i don't know if it should be one of his
old you know [ __ ] chest piece heart
things or whatever they like prove tony
stark has a heart
um
i think that's kind of sweet
um
or maybe it's like an early build of
jarvis
um
i think
i think hulk gives him his first
protractor
it's like we will science kids like
here's the thing that helped me become a
[ __ ]
molecular physicist slash giant green
guy um
yeah
okay
it's just like what's what's my name do
you know who i am have we ever actually
[ __ ] met hawkeye says to peter parker
he's like i'll give you a million
dollars if you could tell me what my
name is
your arrow guy my real name
mulva
[Laughter]
did you see did you see them
oh i was gonna say we don't know lady
gaga poker face but we know a 25 year
old seinfeld joke
did you see it i'm not sure exactly how
accurate this is but there was this bit
going around uh the variety shop they do
their actors on actors sort of award
season things and uh the story was
that uh josh brolin was supposed to be
interviewed he's supposed to have a
conversation with jeremy renner but
renner didn't show
and so they instead asked him to
interview himself
right and it's basically like how great
are you for having been thanos and it's
it's wonderful it's not long it's like a
minute long it's you know built for
[ __ ] tick tock or whatever but it's
so much fun but i do just love the idea
that renner was like [ __ ] you brolin i'm
just not showing up today
um poland's like [ __ ] it i'll interview
myself yeah i got this
um
steve rogers gives him a fake id
go buy yourself some beer buddy you
burned it
captain america yeah
i mean rules isn't it
language cap but it also seems like a
guy who in world war ii was also
drinking at 18 years old because you
could do that on a military base
um
and uh who else was left
i mean dr strange
teaches a magic trick
um
yeah i guess that's it that's close
enough what about like falcon and winter
soldier give him a signed copy of oh the
places you'll go by dr seuss because
don't they have a long discussion about
like
superhero doesn't pay
so
here you go kid
yeah exactly nice
they they give them the gift of the
truth where you're like this is a
job where there's no salary really
yeah i mean if tony was a nice guy he'd
given peter an apartment
dan i look forward to i mean i know it's
going to be [ __ ] years before we get
another spider-man movie but i really
look forward to seeing what they do with
this thread
that they ended on where it's just like
nobody remembers him his friends don't
remember peter parker's alone aunt may's
gone spoilers um
god those movies are good
um
yeah me too [ __ ] that's my happy place
still is
i was telling my mom the other day she
was like what are you what makes you
happy in life tiger i was like um aside
from like my wife and my kid and [ __ ]
marvel movies
i really am she raised a simpleton
she raised me like a puppy so i'm very
easily satisfied
however she raised me she raised me to
know when it was time to [ __ ] go
ah
it's time to go kids 11 o'clock on the
[ __ ] west coast we started this [ __ ]
when
8 15. yeah so we've been going at it for
a minute and a half um
can't thank you enough for coming to
hang out with us uh here online uh
except to say please come hang out with
us
irl as the kids used to say back when
poker face was a hit
so many [ __ ] years ago apparently um
we're having a show
come see fat man beyond right there at
the scum and villainy cantina june 21st
next tuesday next tuesday this coming
tuesday tickets are up at eventbrite.com
i'm sure you could probably get there
through csmodd.com as well
um
you keep your uh
keep your eyes open too for when we drop
tickets i think maybe this week
uh tickets go on sale for
all the san diego shows
we're doing a fat man beyond at night
one of the nights and then get old jay
and sal and bob get old did you be
hollywood babylon but i think we might
be doing
during the day streaming updates
of the news at the end of the night if
mark is free i know he's a busy guy at
comic-con too mm-hmm
yeah it's gonna be fun uh even if you're
someplace else we could stream in and be
like would you like that's true weird
[ __ ]
i'm gonna be good times but before that
happens june 21st
uh
fat man beyond back at the scum and
villainy cantina
oh long as none of us get copied
i'm clean for a while man yeah me too
what do they call that yeah me and jc
we're gonna make out we're so [ __ ]
clean
i'm not talking about tongue kissing i'm
talking about make out like lips to
sphincter that's how [ __ ] ooh
we are that we're not going to get it
again
getting that peach pit
to the peach
uh did you have a good time kids boy i
hope so because i could have been
hanging out with my sainted [ __ ]
mother i hung out with you instead could
you imagine me trying to explain this
whole concept to my mom i was like i'm
doing a show she's like i'll go with you
i was like no i'm doing a show in my
office streaming show she's like what do
you mean i was like i'm gonna talk to
the
computer and uh that's the show and
she's like tiger that's so sad i was
like you have no idea
um all right so i'm gonna go down and
say good night to my mother it's 11
o'clock here man
and i've got uh
some stuff to shoot tomorrow i think
we're shooting with lionsgate's doing
epk for uh clerks three so interviews
about like hey man what's it like to
make clerks again i'm like well let me
tell you
i'm getting good at it
um so i'll be doing that tomorrow and
stuff but don't forget tuesday kids are
you outside of hollywood are you like
i'm nowhere near hollywood well then
come to hollywood
come to hollywood and tell us your dream
what's your dream welcome to hollywood
what's your dream remember pretty woman
just like that
um
there it is kids uh thank you to jc to
banff man himself who can't
he can be seen heard but not seen
because of uh some
technical snap foods that he assures us
will be changed by next week
but even if it wasn't the [ __ ] it's a
free show what do you want
what do you expect for nothing a rubber
biscuit
[Music]
some people keep saying i'm high i'm not
this ain't even me i you should see me i
it's crazy
i'm very affectionate i'm very like you
could do anything
literally
um i believe that though it's not just
high talking that's def smith talking
that's kev smith that is most unguarded
he's not high and out of his mind he's
just like i'm dropping all these
inhibitions that keep me from telling
you
how [ __ ] special you are
you can fly come up to your roof and
jump you can fly
nah you can't do that man but you got
the nuts in this life and i'm not
talking about like testicles because
they're useless i'm talking about the
nuts like the poker nuts you got a
[ __ ] you're holding a goddamn royal
flush you don't even know it well i'll
[ __ ] tell you especially when i'm
stoned cause that's when i'm my most
honest
ready
i like obi-wan kenobi there
i said it
i'm chilling for it without money
because i'm stupid like that
just because i like a thing kids when i
[ __ ] wrote like you know the death
star contractor scene in clerks in 1994
i wasn't shilling for [ __ ] star wars
or disney which didn't even own star
wars then either i just wrote about it
because i like it same thing we talk
about it now because i like it
i wish i
you have no idea how much i wish i could
get paid to just be like oh i get it
because i like a lot of things and that
means i get paid very well but it's not
the case
just a fan just waving a flag because
i'm like look here's something positive
they'll make you forget one day you're
gonna [ __ ] die
watch this
is that something on that note
yeah
yeah
let's bleep everybody go to bed uh
thanks for hanging out man uh there is
no [ __ ] show without the guy who's in
the other box
give it up for the man who goes
deep for the peach pit ladies and
gentlemen
maestro mark bernard look at him
oh god
i can feel myself getting hard and wet
at the same time
uh thank you jc for pumping our show out
there thank you for mark for making the
show interesting and thank you
the home viewer for taking the time and
hanging out
two old men we're like you know statler
and waldorf [ __ ]
balcony of [ __ ] pop culture cracking
wise and [ __ ] like that yes good luck if
you're in the
i don't remember either of those guys
being positive
no this stinks it's horrible
it's more like statler and fozzie
that was really good
um come back soon kids well come watch
the show next week on tuesday either
live in person or of course you can
watch it streaming right here while it
[ __ ] happens and [ __ ]
thanks for coming this week
and uh that
my friends is fat man beyond for this
week i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard
tune in next week same fat time same
fat channel spotcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith
a big old jeff's kiss ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sound bob get old i'm kevin smith